GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO THE FIRST EVER SELECT
COMMITTEE.
ON THE ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
AND I WELCOME EVERYONE TO THIS
FIRST MEETING OF THE SISTINE
GROUP -- I SEE I HAVE TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ALREADY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE SOME OTHER SIMPLY
MEMBERS JOINING.
AND TO MAKE SURE YOU KNOW YOU
ARE IN THE CORRECT ROOM -- I'M
JUST GONNA LET YOU KNOW THAT
THIS ISSUE SINCE I'VE BEEN
ELECTED HAS BEEN.
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME AS
A HAS BEEN TO TO MY COLLEAGUES --
ARE.
I PROBABLY HAVE MENTIONED THIS
SEVERAL TIMES IN SEVERAL
MEETINGS AND MANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN.
THAT I'VE BEEN TO MORE PRISONS
THAN I'VE EVER WANTED TO IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE -- AND AS I TALK TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS ABOUT.
ABOUT HOW THEY GOT.
INTO THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE -- SEEM LIKE IT WAS A
VERY CLEAR PATH.
THAT IS -- NOT ONLY WELL KNOWN
BY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT IS IS AN INSIDIOUS IN NATURE.
AND IT'S AND DELIBERATE --
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS ALSO
RESULTED.
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AFTER
AMERICAN LATINOS NATIVE AMERICAN
AND SOME.
API.
ATKINS BEING THRUST INTO THE
PRISON PIPELINE.
WHICH I LIKE TO CALL THE PRISON
PAL PLANTATION WHICH IS REPLACED
PLANTATIONS OF THE OF SLAVERY
TIME.
AND ONCE YOU'RE IN.
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. TO LEAD
A FULL LIFE.
AND WE HAVE NOT PRESENTED --
WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO TO BE ABLE
TO GET OUT OF THAT A TIME OUT OF
IT?
AND EVERY TIME I'VE MET THESE --
THESE INDIVIDUALS -- A LOT OF
THEM HAVE SAID I WISH THERE WAS
SOMEONE.
THAT I CARED FOR ME WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER -- I THE STORY I'D LIKE
TO TELL AS WELL AS A ROOM FULL
OF AFTER AMERICAN.
MALES -- AND THEY WITH THEIR
BOYS TO MEN OF COLOR THEY WERE
THERE TO TALK ALL THESE ADULTS.
THE TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY NEEDED
TO DO AND THEY HAD A GROUP OF
ABOUT TEN YOUNG MEN.
THAT WERE FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
AND ONE OF THEM GOT UP.
AND SAID THAT -- OF THE REASON
THAT I ENDED UP IN JAIL
INCARCERATED SO LONG IS BECAUSE
NO ONE LISTEN TO ME.
AND OF COURSE ALL THESE MEN GOT
UP TO READ DOCTORS LAWYERS AT PH
DIS.
VERY WELL EDUCATED PEOPLE AT
ELECTED OFFICIALS GET UP AND
SAID WE CARE WE CARE.
AND HE SAID NO.
NO ONE LISTENS TO ME.
AND IT KIND OF TOOK US ALL A
BACK LIKE WHEN.
OF COURSE WE DO IN IN WHICH WE
WE KNEW ABOUT ASUS WE KNEW ABOUT
THIS WHEN WE HAD ALL THESE
TECHNICAL TERMS WE KNEW ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE WERE DOING.
AND THIS ONE OLDER GENTLEMAN
[inaudible]
WHEN UP?
AND STOOD IN FRONT THIS YOUNG
MAN AND SAID -- I HEAR YOU.
AND THEN HE GAVE ME A HUG.
AND HE SAID I CAN TELL THAT
YOU'RE SMART [inaudible]
DAD YOU.
ARE GIFTED AND YOU ARE YOU ARE
SOMEONE THAT WILL BE -- EVAN
CAGES TO THIS COMMUNITY AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU.
AND THAT YOUNG MAN BROKE DOWN
AND STARTED CRYING.
AND THAT I WOULD BE SURE WHAT TO
DO MOST THE MEN WEREN'T SURE
WHAT TO DO.
BEFORE I NOTICE.
THERE WAS.
WE SEE GROWN AFTER AMERICAN
LATINO MEN STARTING TO CRY IN A
ROOM -- YOU REALIZE WHAT HE WAS
SAYING IS NO ONE SEES ME.
SO NO ONE HEARS ME.
AND WHEN I TELL PEOPLE MY PAIN.
NO ONE HEARS ME AND NO ONE SEES
ME AND WHEN HE GOT THE MIKE BACK --
BUT THE THING THAT REALLY
BOTHERED ME HE WAS IT WAS LIKE
NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
AND HE SAID IT WAS THE FIRST
TIME.
ANY MAN OF COLOR HAD EVER TOLD
HIM HE WAS WORTH SOMETHING.
THINK ABOUT THAT HE'S NINETEEN
YEARS OLD AND IT WAS THE FIRST
TIME.
THAT ANYONE OF HIS OWN PEOPLE.
TOLD HIM THAT HE WAS SOMEONE OF
COLOR.
AND I READ.
I THINK EVERYBODY IN THAT ROOM
MADE A COMMITMENT TO TRY TO IN
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
AND WE ALSO KNEW WE HAD TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
AND WE CAN'T JUST KEEP DOING THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER EXPECT
DIFFERENT RESULTS -- THE OTHER
THING THAT CAME OUT OF IT IS
SIDE HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HAD
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA.
THEY TOLD ME THAT -- MAY HAVE
BEEN RAPED.
AND THEN RAPED AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE
OLDER SOME AS YOUNG AS SEVEN OR
FIVE NAY MAKE AGAIN WITH A
TWELVE AND SOMETIMES IS A MALE
RAPING [inaudible]
ANOTHER MALE.
AND THEN THEY GET TO STAY CO
SIBLING KILLED.
DRUG CHARGES ALL OF THAT GOING
ON APPARENT PRISON.
AND EVERYONE IN HERE'S AN ADULT.
AND EVEN AS AN ADULT YOU KNOW
YOU PROBABLY COULDN'T.
MENTALLY.
DEAL WITH THAT.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
AND SO -- I TOLD THE YOUNG MAN
THAT HE'S PROBABLY EXPERIENCING
UP POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
ASUS OR WHATEVER AND HE SAID NO
BROTHER I'M EXPERIENCE
POSTTRAUMATIC ST DISORDER.
BECAUSE WHAT GOES ON IN THE
STREET.
AS MUCH FOR SOMETIMES IN WHAT
GOES ON IN IRAN IRAQ AFGHANISTAN.
AND IT'S ON ME EVERY DAY.
AND SO -- THIS IS WHY -- AFTER
LISTENING TO ALL THOSE.
MEN WHO WERE PRESENT TELLING ME.
HOW THEY WHAT THEY WERE LOOK
WHAT THEIR CHILDHOOD WAS LIKE WE
WERE ABLE WITH THE HELP OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND WE'RE JOINED BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DIDN'T COME
UNDER DOUG.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY --
IT BECAME VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO GET MONEY TO THEM AT EARLY A
SO THEY COULD GET MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND SO WITH THE
HELP OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
WE'RE EXIST ESTABLISHED A USED
REINVESTMENT BOND WHICH PUTS
THIRTY SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON THE STREET IN FACT
THE GRANTS ARE GOING OUT THIS
MONTH TO NONPROFITS IN PEOPLE
DOING GOD'S WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY. TO DEAL WITH POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER SO
THAT WE CAN SAVE OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE -- IN THE STREETS AT HOME.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
GIVEN THAT HUG.
THAT THEY'RE NOT GETTING RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO.
WHEN I ASKED THE SPEAKER ABOUT
PUTTING DISKS THIS COMMITTEE
TOGETHER -- MY GOAL IS NOT ONLY
TO TO IN THIS PROCESS.
BUT TO FINALLY.
COME TOGETHER MAYBE PUT A WHITE
PAPER TOGETHER WITH THE HELP OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
NOT ONLY LOOK AT POLICY CHANGES
WHICH WE DO ALL THE TIME.
I THINK WE KNOW.
WHAT'S GOING ON I NEED TO FIND
SOME SOLUTIONS.
WE NEED TO IDENTIFIED IN INTO A
POLICY STATEMENT THAT MAY BE ONE
OR ALL OF US CAN CARRY.
AND THEN WE CAN ALL UNITE BEHIND
BUDGET REQUESTS.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THE MONEY.
WE CAN ALL MAYBE YOU NIGHT
[inaudible]
NOW.
BECAUSE YOU KNEW YOU WANTED AS
IS MY MEMBERS HERE WILL TELL YOU
YOU REALLY WANT TO GET INTO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IN OCTOBER NOVEMBER DECEMBER
INSTEAD OF FIGHTING TO GET IT IN.
LATER ON OR OR WORST OF ALL
TRYING TO GO TO CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE IN TRYING TO GET IN
LET'S LET'S SET THE BAR Là SAID
WHAT WE WANT NOW.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS COMMITTEE.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO AFFORD THOSE
TYPES OF BILLS AND MOST
IMPORTANT OUT I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
THAT WE WE PUT IN MORE MONEY TO
HELP OUR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE OUT
THERE IN THE STREET AND JUST DO
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
AND THEN ALSO PUT MEASURES OF
SUCCESS WHICH WE HAVEN'T DONE --
WHICH WE DON'T DO WELL.
AND I THINK ALLOWS SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS BUT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT AUTHORED AND IT DIDN'T AND
DINNER.
AND HAVE ENOUGH SHUT UP SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY HEAR PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY PROBABLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
COME UP AND GIVE US SOME
TESTIMONY -- I DON'T WANT ANYONE
TO BE AFRAID WHETHER IN
EDUCATION WHAT YOU'RE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT YOUR PROBATION --
WHERE YOU SEE TO SEE OUR ANYONE
IS DEALING WITH OUR?
OUR JUVENILES I DON'T WANT THEM
TO FEEL AS IF WE'RE TRYING.
TO CUT THE BUDGET OF FIRE PEOPLE.
THIS IS ABOUT IMPROVING THE
SYSTEM AND GET IN THE BEST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO HELP OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE -- CAM FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
WE MAY BE LOOKING AT A SEA
CHANGE IN HOW WE DEAL WITH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
GOVERNOR'S ALREADY POINTED
TOWARD THAT HE'S MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT ARE IN
THE BUDGET.
AND GUESS WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT INPUT
ON WHAT THAT THE FUTURE OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE FOR THE NEXT WHAT FIFTY
YEARS.
AND SO -- YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY AND GOING FORWARD --
COULD BE.
COULD BE VERY CRUCIAL BUT PROP
FIFTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN WE WILL
PUT FORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND I'M AYE IT WILL
THROW IN PROP SIXTY FORTY
CANNABIS.
MONEY ALL OF THAT.
MEANS WE HAVE THE MONEY AND AND
RESOURCES GET THIS DONE WE JUST
NEED TO GET THIS DONE CORRECTLY
AND START TALKING ABOUT OUR I
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE EVERY KID THAT DOES NOT
GO TO PRISON WE SAVE THE STATE
AND TAXPAYERS EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
A YEAR AT THE VERY MINIMUM WE
ONLY I WON'T GET INTO HOMES
TAXES THEY PAY.
ON BECAUSE I KNOW THE PROPERTY
TAXES SALES TAXES -- STATE
INCOME TAXES SO WE COULD WE
COULD BE LOOKING AT A OF OF A
BOOM.
IN OUR A A GENERAL FUND REVENUE
IF WE DO THIS CORRECTLY NET AND
NOT ONLY JUST HAVING A SAFER
STREETS.
SO WITH THAT BEFORE I I'D BRING
GONE -- OUR FIRST STEP PANELISTS
I WOULD OPEN IT UP FOR ANYONE OF
THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE HERE TO TO
MAKE AND HE'S AND COMMENTS.
YES MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER I
WANT I WANT TO THANK YOU -- BUT
BEFORE.
I ENJOY THE LEGISLATURE KNOW YOU
IN SOME OF OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES
ARE HERE THE WORKING ON ON THESE
ISSUES FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND
ONE MIGHT. ONE MIGHT THINK LIKE
FILE.
IT CERTAINLY.
A SURPRISE AND IS THE FIRST TIME
THIS COMMITTEE SET UP BY THEN
THE TIMING IS RIGHT FOR IT
BECAUSE FOR DECADES WE'VE HAD A
OVER A CAR SERRATION WE THAT
LEGISLATIVE -- AND BALLOT
INITIATIVES THAT HAVE -- LED TO
CALIFORNIA BEING THE
INCARCERATION CAPITAL THE WORLD
SO YOU HAVE TO STOP THE BLEEDING
FIRST I THINK SOME THE
LEGISLATION IN RECENT YEARS.
HAS REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT -- ON
ON STOPPING THE MANDATORY
MINIMUMS GETTING WHAT IS ON
THESE MANDATORY ENHANCEMENTS
WORKING ON RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
ISSUES BOTH IN THE PRESIDENT
SPOKE SKINNER -- AS OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE PARTICULAR GET RELEASED
SAID THE TIMING IS EXCELLENT NOW
TO REALLY.
DIVE DEEP ON THE EDUCATION SIDE
BECAUSE AND BY THE WAY WE HAVE
EXCELLENT SPEAKERS THAT ARE HERE
TODAY AND I AYE.
AYE BUT FOR THOSE THAT KNOW I
DON'T KNOW I WORKED AS A DEADLY
PUBLIC DEFENDER FROM ELEVEN
YEARS BEFORE.
GETTING INTO ELECTED OFFICE AND
WHEN I WAS PUBLIC DEFENDER BACK
IN NINETY SEVEN I NEVER WOULD
HAVE IMAGINED.
THAT WE WOULD BE HERE TODAY
TALKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
FRANKLY THERE WOULD IMAGINE SOME
OF THE BILLS THAT WE'VE GOTTEN --
OF A SIGN AND A LOT OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS TO REALLY TURN
THERE'S A MASSIVE SHIP OF
INCARCERATION AROUND AND INSTEAD.
TO FOCUS ON ON HEALING AB AND
NOTHING YOU STATE IT CORRECTLY
AND I'VE NO BASEBALL A LOT OF
THE PLANS I HAVE.
INCLUDING MANY THAT WERE FACING
LIFE IN PRISON YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT WE TALKED TO THEM TO LEARN
ABOUT THEIR LIFE STORY -- IT'S A
MIRACLE THAT THEY'RE STILL ALIVE --
THAT ALONE -- THE SITUATION
THEY'RE IN AND SO I'M JUST
GRATEFUL TO BE PART OF THIS TEAM
OF BOTH TEAM UP HERE AS WELL AS
OUT IT IN THE AUDIENCE AND MANY
THAT AREN'T EVEN IN THIS ROOM.
THEY'RE GOING TO HELP US
CONTINUE.
TO CHART THE RIGHT PATH AND IF I
DO LEAVE I HAVE FOR COMMITTEE.
FOR SENATE BILLS AT THE PRESENT
THIS MORNING SO -- FOR THOSE OF
YOU KNOW BECAUSE I SAT DOWN
SENATE OUT -- BUT SOMEONE THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING IT OUT OF
DISRESPECT BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE
OTHER THINGS TO ATTEND TO BUT
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEING SPOKEN.
BUT EVERYTHING'S BEEN RECORDED
AND THIS WILL BE PART OF THE
RECORD AND THAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN IT AND THEY GET I
WILL REITERATE WE HAVE MEMBERS
HAVE TO GO IN AND OUT.
AND HE JUST BE RELIEVED THAT
SUMMARY DOING.
YOU KNOW RACIAL BIAS LEGISLATION
THAT WE NEED TO GET DONE SO WE
WANT THEM TO GO TO THOSE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS.
AND AND GET IT TO THE SENATE SO --
AND EVERYONE ON HERE IS WORKING
ON SOMETHING THAT'S VITAL TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE SO -- OF
JUST KNOW THAT THEY'RE DOING
GOD'S WORK WHEN THEY LEAVE.
ANYONE ELSE AT WE'RE JOINED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARILLO.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WILL MAKE A
STATEMENT.
WIDE ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE -- TO MY RIGHT --
SHARED I WANT TO THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
SENIOR -- FOR ASKING FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND FOR CONTINUING
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
pBEEN WORKING -- ON YOU KNOW HOW
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF LAWS
THAT FIND THEIR WAY INTO THE
PENAL CODE MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
WORKING. TO FIND A WAY TO
ABOLISH AND CLOSE THE PRISONS --
AND MANY OF US CERTAINLY HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON SHINING A LIGHT
ON THE BUSINESS OF INCARCERATION --
WHICH STARTS AT VERY VERY EARLY
AGES RIGHT THERE IS REVENUE
THAT'S GENERATED FROM.
PROFILING THERE'S REVENUE
GENERATED FROM INCARCERATING
THERE'S REVENUE GENERATED FROM
DISCIPLINING THERE'S REVENUE
GENERATED FROM -- INCARCERATION
AND THERE'S REVENUE GENERATED
FROM FAULTY REHABILITATION.
AND AND THAT ENTIRE CYCLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT
AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
INFUSE THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT THEY
DO -- THE CULTURAL RELATIONSHIP
IN THE HISTORICAL RELATIONSHIP
THEY HAVE FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SERVE AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE POWER
OF EDUCATION.
ESPECIALLY IN AND FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND SO ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY I'M VERY
EXCITED.
ABOUT THIS -- COMMITTEE IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT WILL AFFORD
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
THE POWER THAT EDUCATION HAS IN
BREAKING THE PIPELINE BEFORE I
AM JOINED THE LEGISLATURE I WAS
ALSO ON THE BOARD OF THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
AND I CAN RECALL HAVING A
CONVERSATION BEFORE THE START OF
THE SESSION WITH A NUMBER OF
FACULTY MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT
THE FEARS.
THAT PROFESSORS HAVE DEALING
WITH STUDENTS.
AND SIMPLE THINGS LIKE I'M.
SAYING A STUDENT'S NAME.
RECOGNIZING THEM.
A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT WE MAY NOT
KNOW THEIR PAST AND SO GIVING A
COUPLE OF EXTRA SECONDS --
ENCOURAGING FOLKS.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE THE
ETIQUETTE THAT -- EVERYONE SORT
OF OWNS INTO WHEN THEY DECIDE TO
BECOME A STUDENT AT A SCHOOL
RIGHT HOW I TREAT YOU AS A
PROFESSOR IS HOW I WANT YOU TO
TREAT ME -- EXCEPT AROUND AND
AND AND BECAUSE OF BIAS CITIES
BECAUSE OF THOMAS.
THAT THERE HAD BEEN A DISCONNECT
AND IT WAS A IT WAS A SOBERING
IT WAS AN HONEST CONVERSATION
HAD BETWEEN FACULTY MEMBERS --
AND THE FACILITATOR ON HOW -- TO
HE'LL OR REFOCUS THE KINDS OF
ENERGY THAT THEY WERE SAYING IN
THE CLASSROOMS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
80% OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND ARE POOR.
AND AND FACULTY MEMBERS WERE
SAYING YOU KNOW WE'RE HAVING
CHALLENGES TEACHING -- BUT
LOOKING AT THE HUMANITY THE
HUMAN SIDE OF THE STUDENT -- WAS
AN EXCELLENT WAY TO KIND OF KEEP
IT REAL AND BRING IT CLOSE TO
HOME.
AND SO HAVING THOSE KINDS OF
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS AND ALSO TALKING
ABOUT WHO'S ON THE SELECTION IN
THE HIRING COMMITTEES -- YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
HIRING FACULTY AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE DIVERSE WELL IF IF
CERTAIN FOLKS ARE ON THE
COMMITTEE THEN THEY'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO HIRE CERTAIN FOLKS --
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF THOSE FOLKS LOOK LIKE THE
FOLKS THAT THEIR TEACHING.
THOSE ARE SMALL BUT VERY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK VITAL
PARTS OF THIS OVERALL
CONVERSATION AS WE LOOK AT
DISMANTLING THIS PIPELINE AND SO
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR FROM THE
FOLKS WILL BE SPEAKING TODAY.
AND I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW --
THAT EVEN THOUGH I WILL HAVE TO
LEAVE TO ALSO PRESENT THAT I CAN
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER ME
AN ALLY IN AN ADVOCATE IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND THAT'S IN THIS
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE ALSO.
WE COMPANION WITH OTHER
COMMITTEES SELECT COMMITTEE ON
BOYS MEDICAL WHICH I USED TO
CHAIR IS STILL GOING NAY WILL
STILL BRING UP ISSUES.
THIS COMMITTEE WILL HOPEFULLY
MAKE THEM.
ACTUAL AND REAL WHICH THAT YOU
CAN TOUCH AND I JUST WANTED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- COMMA DOUG
ALSO MENTIONS HER SELECT
COMMITTEE WHICH I THINK IS A
COMPANION PIECE TO THIS
COMMITTEE WITH A QUICK DISTRICT
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING. THREE THE CLERK
WAS COOLEY SAID LADIES FIRST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING A GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS WENDY
CARILLO I REPRESENT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY ONE WHICH
INCLUDES THE NORTHEAST LA
COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING --
DODGER STADIUM AND ALL OF AN
INCORPORATED BASED LA.
I WAS BORN IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY IN NINETEEN
TOTALLY DATING MYSELF AND THAT'S
OKAY.
ANDI SAY THAT BECAUSE NINETEEN
EIGHTY IS THE YEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA BEGAN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TWENTY TWO
PRESENTS FOR THE STATE.
IT IS MY GENERATION.
THAT HAS BEEN LITERALLY.
IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
I WENT TO ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS AT A TIME IN
THE LATE NINETIES.
WHEN THERE WERE -- AT THE TIME
THREE DIFFERENT TRACKS AB AND C..
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS FOR A
CLASS FOR A SCHOOL BUILT.
FOR FIFTEEN HUNDRED HALF OF MY
CLASS STRIPPED OUT.
I DROPPED OUT.
AND I WAS FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
TEACHER AND A PRINCIPAL WHO
CARED ENOUGH TO NOTICE THAT I
WAS MISSING. TO BE ABLE TO BRING
ME BACK INTO SCHOOL.
AND SINCE THIRD GRADE.
I HAD BEEN IN THE MAGNET COURSE.
SO IN HIGH SCHOOL I GOT KICKED
OUT OF THE MAGNET PROGRAM I GOT
PUT INTO WHICH WAS ON THE TRACK.
GOT PUT INTO THE HONOR CLASSES
ON EIGHT TRACK WHICH WAS A
TRADITIONAL TRACK AT THE TIME.
GOT KICKED OUT OF HONORS GOT PUT
INTO THE COLLEGE CORE CURRICULUM.
GOT KICKED OUT OF THAT AND
FINALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
THIRD GRADE I WAS IN A REGULAR
CLASSROOM.
AND AS A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SAW
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THE INCREDIBLE DIFFERENCES IN
THE CLASSROOM SETTING.
STILL DIDN'T CARE BECAUSE I WAS
UP TO MY OWN SHENANIGANS AT THE
TIME AS A TEENAGER.
GOT KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL AND GOT
FOR ONE DAY AND ROLLED AND
RAMONA HIGH SCHOOL IN EAST LA.
WHICH WAS AT THE TIME.
A SCHOOL FOR PREGNANT GIRLS.
I WASN'T PREGNANT AND I WAS LIKE
WHAT AM I DOING HERE.
RIGHT -- GOT AND LEFT AT SCHOOL
AND FINALLY.
SOMEONE CALLED MY MOM.
AND MY MOM HAD NO IDEA THAT I
HAD BEEN TRUANT.
THAT I HAD BEEN MISSING.
THAT I WASN'T GOING TO SCHOOL.
AT THE TIME -- THE CITY ATTORNEY
ALSO HAD I THINK IT WAS A CITY
BY CITY CO OWNER I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT IS BUT IT WAS A TIME IN
WHICH PARENTS WERE BEING FINED
IF YOUR KIDS WERE BEING TRUANT.
AND SO PARENTS WERE ALSO GOING
TO JAIL FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
PAY THE TRUNK FEES.
THIS WAS ALL HAPPENING IN THE
LATE NINETIES I WAS FORTUNATE
THAT I GOT PUT BACK IN SCHOOL
THE RULES OF ALL HIGH SCHOOL HAD
AN ADULT SCHOOL PROGRAM WHICH IS
WHY.
I ALSO THINK ADULT EDUCATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
AND I WAS ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
FROM SEVEN IN THE MORNING UNTIL
EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT AND CATCH
UP TO ALL MY CREDITS.
AND FINALLY -- BE AT THE GRADE
LEVEL WHERE I NEEDED TO BE IN
WHAT WAS THEN THE SECOND
SEMESTER OF SENIOR YEAR.
AND I WAS ABLE TO GRADUATE ON
TIME WITH MY CLASS AND ON STAGE
BUT IT BARELY HAPPY.
I SHARE THAT BECAUSE I THINK OUR
PERSONAL STORIES AS LEGISLATORS.
HAVE A CONNECTION TO THE WORK
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE THAT WE
REPRESENT THAT WE ARE.
ENTRUSTED TO REPRESENT.
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
DO THE WORK THAT'S NECESSARY.
BECAUSE TWENTY TWO PRESENTS
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY AS THE
GENERATION.
IT'S MY IS MY GENERATION.
AND SO THE FACT THAT WE SPEND
MORE.
IN THE INCARCERATION OF PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PER
YEAR AT THE TONE OF SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
MORE THAN THE ANNUAL TUITION AT
HARVARD.
AND ONLY SPEND INVEST FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR SO IN PER
PUPIL SPENDING.
IS NOT THE VALUES OF A
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATURE OR THE
VALUES OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE I AM PROUD TO
ALSO BE THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON YOUNG WOMEN
YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN OF COLOR.
WHICH WERE BRINGING BACK WHICH
ALSO PLAYS A ROLE IN THE WORK
THAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO HERE
AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD. TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS ON HOW WE%
ENSURE THAT EDUCATION IS A
PRIORITY TO THE CONVERSATION
WHEN WE DISCUSS THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
TO THIS HEARING AND HEARING WHAT
THE EXPERTS HAVE TO SAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
[inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
WELL I AM VERY PLEASED TO HAVE
THIS HEARING UNFOLDING THE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
CONVENE THIS GROUP.
AND I GUESS THERE IS A PERSONAL
STORY FROM MY SIDEBUT IT'S MORE
JUST HOW I THINK ABOUT THINGS
WHAT'S ON MY MIND AS I WALK.
INTO THIS HEARING.
AND AS I'M WALKING DOWN HERE
TODAY I'M ACTUALLY THINKING OF
AN ACCOUNT IN THE NEW TESTAMENT.
THE BOOK OF LUKE.
THE SIXTEENTH CHAPTER.
WHERE JESUS TELLS A LITTLE STORY
HE SAYS THERE WAS A RICH MAN?
THIS ALL WE KNOW ABOUT THE GUY
HE WAS RICH.
DOESN'T SAY HE WAS PERSONABLE.
THAN SAY HE WAS LOVED.
DOESN'T SAY HE WAS A GOOD
CHARACTER.
AND ALSO EVOLVING SAY ABOUT
SHOES YOU WERE RICH.
YOU'RE PRETTY POOR INDEED.
THAT'S ALL THEY CAN SAY ABOUT
YOU.
IF YOU'RE RICH.
AND THIS RICH MAN STANDS OUT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A A BAKER
LAZARUS.
WHO LAID HIS DOOR?
AND IT WOULD HAVE GIVEN ANYTHING
TO GET EVEN THE CRUMBS FROM THIS
RICH MAN'S TABLE.
AND SO YOU SORT OF SEE THIS
PICTURE OF SOME.
BUDDY SOME ENTITY THAT IS
ABUNDANTLY PROSPEROUS.
WITH NO HEART. FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT THE BACK DOOR.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DEEP NEED.
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
HONESTLY PROBABLY LAZARUS MADE
THE RICH MAN UNCOMFORTABLE.
IN HIS ABUNDANCE.
AND I SORT OF SEE AN AD A
PICTURE.
OF HOW AN ABUNDANT CALIFORNIA'S
SOCIETY.
CAN PREFERRED TO KEEP SOME
PEOPLE IN THE BACKDROP.
SO WE'RE NOT CALL TO MIND THE
NEEDS AROUND AND ARE BOUND.
IT IS IN PART OF THIS STORY
JESUS SAYS -- EVENTUALLY LAZARUS
DIES HE GOES TO HEAVEN THE RICH
MAN ENDS UP IN HADES.
SAYS CAN YOU GO COULD LATERALLY
SCHOOL WORN MY BROTHERS.
THEY WILL DO WHAT I DID.
AND RESPONSE FROM JESUS IS TELLS
A STORY WELL IF HE DIDN'T LISTEN.
TO MOSES AND THE PROPHETS.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA LISTEN.
SO REALLY IN THIS STORY OF THE
RICH MAN AND LAZARUS WHICH I
RELATE TO SEPARATE MATTER THIS
HEARING -- JESUS SAYS THIS
MEASURES.
HOW YOU RELATE TO THE WHOLE LAWN
THE PROFITS THE ENTIRE?
LEGACY OF THAT FAITH.
COMES DOWN TO THIS.
SO I JUST FEEL THAT THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
IT RAISES FOR US IN PUBLIC
POLICY.
THE THAT THIS WILL BECOME SORT
OF THE MEASURE OF US.
MEASURE OF OUR SOCIETY -- ONE
COULD DARE SAY THAT ON SOME
LEVEL WE WILL BE JUDGED BY HOW
WE HOW WE APPROACH.
BEEN ACTIVE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEED US AND OUR
INTERVENTIONS ABOVE ALL ELSE.
SO I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THIS HEARING BUT SO THAT'S
THAT'S SORT OF WHAT I WOULD
BRING IN THE ROOM TODAY
[inaudible] SIXTEEN THANK YOU
REVEREND COOLEY FOR BLESSEDNESS.
IN MAKING SURE WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK.
AND SO -- LET ME BRING UP OUR
FOR OUR FOR OUR FIRST SPEAKER
AND AND AN OUTSIDE PERSPECTIVE
FOLLOW ALONG ON THE ON THE
AGENDA WE WILL BEGIN WITH AN
OUTSIDE PERSPECTIVE ON THE ROLE
OF TEACHERS.
AND ENDING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE I WANNA THANK EVERYONE
FOR COMING HERE TODAY AND I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST SPEAKER.
DR JOE MARSHALL.
DOCTOR MARSHALL IS A MAC ARTHUR
GENIUS AWARD.
AND OPRAH'S USE YOUR BEST LIFE
AWARDS.
AS WELL AS A BEST SELLING AUTHOR
LECTURER.
AND AND OUR AWARD WINNING RADIO
TALK SHOW -- OF STREET SOLDIERS
ARE ON K. M. E. L..
WITH THAT I WILL ALLOW DOCTOR
MARSH'S SPEAK ON THE ISSUE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF ENDING THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMAN JONES
SAWYER -- I KNOW THESE THINGS GO
FAST SO I AND I PUT TOGETHER
THIS AMOUNT OF PLAY HAS IS.
QUICK ONE PAGER THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO LOOK AT ON THE BACKSIDE
IS WHO I AM BUT YOU JUST DID
THAT SO THAT MAKES IT EASY --
BECAUSE LATIMES WATER WE HAVE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF IN THE BIO
AND ALL OF THAT THAT'S ON THE
BACKSIDE OF THE DAILY NO IF YOU
HAVE IT I THINK IT'S WITH A LOT
OF PAPER.
THANK YOU HAVE THEM WITH YOU.
ARE.
BIGGER YEAH OKAY AND THEN ON THE
FRONT SIDE OF THIS IS THE
PROGRAM THAT I DO THAT DESCRIBES
ALL PROGRAMS SERVICES SO I
THOUGHT.
IF YOU READ DEAD REAL QUICKLY
WOULD JUST CUT THROUGH.
AREAS YEAH IT THERE IT IS THAT
WOULD CUT TO MAKE A LOT OF I
DON'T THINK YEAH I DON'T THINK
HE GOT PASSED OUT.
SO YEAH I THINK YOU NEED TO PASS --
I HAVE IT OFF YES YOU HAVE --
WELL YEAH.
THERE WE GO.
SO THE BACK IS ME IT'S A
PARAGRAPH.
AND IN THE FRONT IS A PROGRAMMER
SCRIPT IF YOU TAKE A MOMENT AND
READ DOES THIS SORT OF JUST
SECURE PAN TO WITH.
AND AND MADE NOTES THEN I THINK
IT THIS IS A MATTER OF TIME
WOULD BE MORE.
WILL BE BETTER SERVED.
AND YOU CAN MAY JUST WANT TO ASK
THE QUESTION RIGHT AWAY.
OKAY PROTESTS ON INTEREST TIME
MAYBE ONE JUST BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY HAS YEAH BUT IF YOU
WANT TO GO OVER.
WHAT ALIVE AND FREE WILL MAKE A
BOYS CLUB DOES SO I'LL ALARM
FREE IS A PROGRAM THAT I STARTED
NOW THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO TO
BASICALLY JUST DO THAT?
KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE ALIVE.
AND UNHARMED BY ABOUT THE FREE
FROM A CAR SERRATION IT WAS NOT
ORIGINALLY CALLED I'M FREE
ACTUALLY WAS CALMING ABILITY
WILL BE A BOYS CLUB.
BUT SINCE I HAD GIRLS FROM THE
BEGINNING.
TAUGHT THAT AT SOME POINT -- IT
WAS A BIT OF A MISNOMER SO WE
HAVE SINCE THEN CHANGED THE THE
NAME TO ALIVE AND FREE ALTHOUGH
THE KIDS JUST CALL AT THE CLUB --
I WAS A TEACHER ADMINISTRATOR
FOR YEARS.
ACTUALLY STARTED PROGRAM BECAUSE
I WAS A MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS AND AND AND
SAM'S IS GONE THEN BECAME AN
ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL AND FIGURED
IF THE KIDS GOOD SURVIVING IN
THE CLASSROOM EVERYTHING WAS
GONNA BE OKAY.
BECAUSE I WAS ONE OF THOSE.
DEMANDING INSTRUCTORS GAVE A LOT
OF HOMEWORK.
YOU KNOW THE KIND OF TIAS HATED
BACK MY NICKNAME WITH ME MISTER
MARSHALL -- BUT THEY GOT GOOD
GRADES ON ME AND WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL I
JUST FIGURED EVERYTHING WAS
GOING TO BE GOOD.
BUT SOMETHING SEEN THAT HAPPEN
WHEN THEY GOT THE HIGH SCHOOL
AND MY KIDS WOULD END UP EITHER
PREGNANT OR IN JAIL FOR SELLING
DRUGS OR THERE.
AND I WILL GO TO FUNERALS AND I
DID COULDN'T TAKE IT SO I
DECIDED.
TO REALIZE THAT BEING A GOOD
TEACHER WASN'T ENOUGH SO I START
IS ORGANIZATION IT WAS AN AFTER
SCHOOL THING -- I TOLD THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IF THEY COULD STICK WITH
THE PROGRAM I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THEM.
I DECIDED NOT TO DO JOBS BECAUSE
I CAN'T CONTROL THE ECONOMY.
I JUST SAID THAT THE IF YOU
STICK WITH THIS IF YOU'RE IN
INTO VIOLENCE DRUGS TO GET OUT
AND IF YOU'RE NOT AT THE END
DON'T GET IN.
THE SOMEONE WANT TO DO FOR YOU
AND A LOOK MISS IT WOULD.
AS A YOU PICKED A COLLEGE NOW
FIND THE MONEY NOW ALSO PEOPLE
DON'T DO THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY MONEY.
I WAS NOT A VENTURE CAPITALIST I
DID NOT HAVE A I WAS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER -- BUT WHEN THE
YOUNG PEOPLE TOLD ME THAT THEY
WERE WILLING TO DARE TO BE
DIFFERENT WHICH IS A PHRASE WE
USE.
AND IN THOSE DAYS WE HAD T.
SHIRTS IS THAT I DON'T DO DRUGS
AND STUFF ABOUT THEM MORE
WILLING TO COMMIT TO THAT.
I FIGURED IT I WOULD COMMITTED
THEM AND WE HAVE A BUNCH OF
SAYINGS AND ONE IS IF YOU DO
GOOD THINGS GOOD THINGS WILL
COME TO YOU.
AND THE THE REST OF THIS IS JUST
WHEN A MIRACULOUS HISTORY THAT --
THE MONEY HAS COME THE KIDS HAVE
GRADUATED MY FIRST COLLEGE
GRADUATE WITH THE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE A YOUNG LADY FROM
SAN FRANCISCO STATE.
MY FIRST MALE COLLEGE GRADUATE
WAS A NINETEEN NINETY FOUR A
MORE FOR MORRIS BROWN COLLEGE HE
WAS MY FIRST.
JAIL HOUSE IS A SCHOOL HOUSE
YOUNG MAN.
OF A AND THIS YEAR I'M
CELEBRATING COLLEGE GRADUATE
NUMBER -- TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT IT'S JUST BEEN REMARKABLE --
THE SO THERE'S SOME COMMON
THINGS HERE.
THERE'S ALL KIND OF THE STORES
ALL CON ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE.
IN MY COLLEGE GRADUATION RATE IS
91%.
ALMOST EVERY KID I SEND A
COLLEGE GRADUATES -- I
PERSONALLY RAISE THE MONEY AND
HELP PAY FOR THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION -- I'VE HAD ALL KIND
OF YOUNG PEOPLE I MET A YOUNG
MAN IN.
IN YOUTH AUTHORITY FOR THREE
COUNTS OF ARMED ROBBERY AND
ATTEMPTED MURDER ON A POLICE
OFFICER HE GOT OUT.
AND THE GRADUATE MORE HOUSE -- I
HAVE YOUNG A YOUNG LADY LAST
CAME LAST NIGHT WHEN SHE GOT
THERE LAST NIGHT YOU SAID YOU
KNOW I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING I
DON'T DO ANYTHING.
BUT I CAME HERE BECAUSE I WAS A
GOOD KID AND THIS WAS A
PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR ME SO I
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT -- SO
WE GET.
IT IS IT IS A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
THING.
WHAT IS THE WORK WE HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION A PRESCRIPTION IS?
WHAT MAKES IT IS IS VERY
DIFFERENT WE'RE NOT A REGULAR
PROGRAM WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION YOU'VE HEARD THINGS
ABOUT THE MESSAGE BEING BIGGER
THAN A MESSENGER? FOR THIS
PRESCRIPTION THAT WE USE IS TO
PREVENT YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
GETTING IN A MINDSET THAT ENDS
UP MEANT ENDS ENDS THEM IN THE
PRISON.
OR IT ALSO PREVENTS THEM -- IF
THEY'RE ALREADY THERE IT GETS
THEM OUT OF IT SO.
HELLO WHAT I DO IS TEACH OTHER
PEOPLE PUT THE PRESCRIPTION I
NEVER WANT TO FRANCHISE THE
ORGANIZATION I WANT TO TEACH THE
METHODOLOGY.
HELLO WELL I WHAT I DO IS
ACTUALLY TEACH OTHER PEOPLE HOW
TO KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE ALIVE AND
FREE -- I HAVE DISCIPLES OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS EVERYONE PUT IT.
AROUND CALIFORNIA LITERALLY
AROUND.
THE WORLD.
I'M GOING TO A SOUTH AFRICAN IN
A FEW MONTHS TO DO WORK WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE THERE BECAUSE THE
ISSUES OF THE SAME REALLY
WHEREVER YOU GO -- AND I'M JUST
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO THIS AS
pJOB IS TO KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE LIVE
FOR FREE.
ANYTHING ASIDE.
BECAUSE I WAS DOING THIS SO WELL.
WE JUST ALL THESE IN BECAUSE
THIS IS TAKING ME INTO PLACES I
NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD GO.
HE'S OUR OUR GOVERNOR NOW BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND FORM THEN MERRIN
NEWSLOOK POINTED ME TO THE
POLICE COMMISSION FOR THE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
REFORMING THE POLICE WHICH IS
HARD TO WORK WITH THE KIDS WITH
A LOVE STORY.
BUT WE'VE BEEN THE ONLY SEASONAL
HAND IN HAND BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT THE POLICE STAFF TO DO MY
YOUNG AND WHEN THEY DO DO WITH
THEM.
I WANTED TO DO WHEN AN EQUITABLE
EQUITABLE MANNER -- SO.
THAT'S THE THE CLIFF NOTES REAL
QUICK -- YOU CAN ASK ANYTHING
YOU LIKE A I DON'T WANT TO TOO
GOOD TO BE TRUE PEOPLE I BELIEVE
YOU DO WHAT NO OTHER POSSIBLE
BUT IS ACTUALLY TRUE AND THAT'S
WHAT BRAVE WHEN PRISON YOU
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY WORKS.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LOOK AT YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE LOOKING [inaudible]
YEAH.
A COUPLE OF HOURS IF YOU GUYS
USED TO DO SO.
TURN YOUR AYE AYE.
MOST APPROPRIATE THING TO DO --
SO I SAID ON PUBLIC SAFETY WITH --
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
EVERY WEEK WE ARE REVIEWING
LEGISLATIVE POLICY.
I'M NOT THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
EXPANDING THE PENAL CODE.
AND WHAT I FIND IS THAT -- WE
TEND TO WANT TO DEFINE FOLKS BY
THEIR ACTIONS SO IF YOU DID.
X. YOU SHOULD GET SEVEN YEARS
TWELVE YEARS YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GONNA BE PROHIBITIONS ASSESS TWO
YEAR -- CIVIL LIBERTIES.
AND TO HEAR YOU TALK AND THEN
ALSO TO HEAR YOU SHARE THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING TO REFORM
THE POLICE COMMISSION I WAS
RUNNING IF YOU COULD JUST SHARE
BRIEFLY YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO KIND OF
HELP.
POLICY MAKERS AND OF THOSE.
IN AUTHORITY TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE DON'T NEED TO NECESSARILY
DEFINE FOLKS JUST BY YOU KNOW
THE ONE OR A FEW BAD ACTIONS --
BECAUSE THAT CAN HAVE A
DISASTROUS IMPACT ON THE JOURNEY
THAT THEY ALTERNATELY HAVE TO
TAKE -- I GUESS WITH THE WORD WE
USE THIS PROFILING -- IT WORKED
WITH THE POLICE HAS BEEN
FASCINATING BECAUSE OF ONE TIME
ONE TIME THE KIDS TOLD ME.
OUT OF THIS AS A QUESTION AT THE
KIDS SOMEBODY PLEASE ARE JUST
LIKE A GANG OF CIVIL ONE WHETHER
THERE'S A GAME TO SAY -- ON THEY
WERE COLORS AND AND THEY DON'T.
THEY DON'T TELL ON THE JONES.
A SURVEY DOWN FOR THE HOME WE
RIGHT A WRONG GUESS THE WAY THEY
PUT IT.
AND SO ACTUALLY A BIG HAND IN
THE OTHER THING IS THAT IS THAT
IS THE THING ABOUT THE POLICE
LOOKING AT PROFILING THE
COMMUNITY LOOKING THEM ALL
THROUGH THE SAME LAND -- THAT.
THAT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE IT
NEVER EVEN ENTERS INTO MY ROOM
AND WHEN A KID WALKS IN AND I
SEE HIM I DON'T EVEN SEE THEIR
KI<c.cyan> FOLDER I DON'T EVEN LOOK</c>
AT IT.
AND LOOK AT ALL I DON'T WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE HISTORY.
AS AN INSTRUCTOR LET ME TELL YOU
THE TOUGHEST PLACE TO ME WAS
GOING INTO THE TEACHER'S LOUNGE.
BUT I WANT TO SEE TO LOUNGE OR
THEM TO EAT LOTS OF THE TEACHERS
I WOULD HEAR FROM THE THE
TEACHERS YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE KIDS JUST CAN'T DO IT.
AND THEY SAID THEY COULDN'T DO
IT.
BASICALLY THERE WERE THREE
THINGS.
THE REASONS WHERE THEY LIVE IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEIR MOTHERS ON DRUGS -- IF I
WAS IN JAIL HE GOT HIS START.
AND YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT YOU'RE A BAD TEACHER THEY
JUST CAN'T DO IT WELL MY YOU SHE
WAS THAT I HAD THE SAME KIDS.
AND THEY WERE GET PAYS A BREEZE
FOR ME.
SO MY SENSE OF UNDERSTANDING.
WAS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THERE'S
NOW EVEN PUT IT THERE BASICALLY
THE EXPECTATIONS I HAVE FOR THEM
WERE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
THAN WHAT THEY HAVE FOR THEM.
SO DAY ROLLS TO MIND BUT
PROBABLY PUBLIC SCHOOLS I'M HARD
OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS OUT.
THERE FOR YEARS IS THAT THEY'RE
EXPECTING IF YOU TALK TO ANY
YOUNG PERSON.
AND I TALK TO KIDS IN THE THIRD
GRADE TO HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY TELL ME ABOUT.
TEACHERS AND I NOTICED THAT WHEN
I COME A TELL ME TELL ME TWO
THINGS THEY ALWAYS SAY THEY
DON'T LIKE US AND I DON'T THINK
WE CAN DO IT.
NOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET THERE
AND THAT.
IF YOU WATCH A KINDERGARTEN
CLASS WHATEVER CATEGORICALLY
ASKING THE QUESTION.
THEY CAN SET UP BY THE TIME WE
GET TO THE FOURTH GRADE.
THEY HAVE SHUT DOWN.
WHEN I GET TO HIGH SCHOOL YOU
ASKED A QUESTION IS COOL
DEPARTMENT LIKE START TO GO OUT
THERE EARLY?
DOES KIDS SENSE VERY ALL YOUR
OWN I DON'T AND AND YOU KNOW.
BLACK BOYS IN PARTICULAR BUT YOU
COULD STORE BY IN THERE THAT DAY
JUST THIS ISN'T SCHOOL IS NOT
THE PLACE FOR US SCHOOLS ART BAY
THEY BEGIN TO BELIEVE THAT IT IS
WHEN THEY FIRST GO.
BUT AFFORD GREAT THIRD GRADE
THEY REALIZED THIS IS THE PLACE
WITH THEM SO THEY BEGIN TO SHUT
DOWN -- ALL OF THEIR EMPLOYEE
HERE IT'S JUST LOOKING AT
PROBLEM PROP OUR PROBLEM WITH
POLICE IS THE BASS IS A BRAIN.
TO THEY BRING TO THE THE SETTING
RIGHT.
THEY JUST SEE.
THINGS DIFFERENTLY THEN THEN I
AM A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY I'M SO.
THIS CAN ALL BE AN OUTRIGHT WHEN
I DO THE TRAININGS I TRY TO
CORRECT ALL OF THIS BUT DANCE IN
PLAY WITH ALL OF THESE.
ALL THESE FOLKS TO INTERACT WITH
THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHICH CONTRIBUTES.
TO THE WAY THEY SEE THEMSELVES
AND BEGINS TO LEAD THEM DOWN TO
A PATH.
THAT THEY THINK YOU KNOW IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY BECAUSE
THIS IS BASICALLY PEOPLE HAVE TO
FIND THEM.
AS PEOPLE LIKE THEY JUST CAN'T
DO THANK YOU.
OR ANY QUESTIONS A MYSTICAL
[inaudible]
SO.
A LIVE IN FREE THE OMEGA BOYS
CLUB IT'S IN THE BAY FEW BAYVIEW
AREA SO IT HAMMER I'M MOSTLY
JUST CURIOUS HOW YOU DETERMINE
TO SETTLE WHERE YOU SETTLED.
AND STARTED THIS OUT SOLANO I
DETERMINE HOW HOW YOU DECIDE TO
TO BE WHERE YOU'RE AT LONG AGO.
IT WHAT WAS PULLED YOU TO THAT
SPOT OBVIOUS YOU BEEN.
DOING SOMETHING GREAT FOR A LONG
TIME.
I JUST SORT OF A LITTLE PERSONAL
COMMENTARY I STARTED I NEED TO
PLACE AN AND A COMMUNITY CENTER
UP OF THE THREE FOR ME.
BECAUSE I WAS TEACHING IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAM'S OFFICE --
HILL THE GAME IS CENTER FOR FREE.
THE FIRST KIDS WERE BASICALLY MY
KIDS ON THE SCHOOL AND FRIENDS.
DAY WHEN TOLL OTHER PEOPLE SO I
BECAME.
A SAN FRANCISCO THING AND THEN
IT BECAME A BAY AREA THING AND
THEN PEOPLE SAID WELL.
YOU KNOW I GOT KIDS IN PASADENA
SO HOW DO YOU TEACH ME TEACH ME
HOW TO DO IT A PASADENA IT'S THE
WORD OF MOUTH IS GOT AROUND.
AND SO HE IS HEADQUARTERED THERE
BUT WHEN I SAY LIBERALLY THAT.
SOME IN SOUTH AFRICA IS THE
DOCTOR MARSHALL SOUTH AFRICA AS
WE CALL THEM STILL.
IS BECAUSE THE THEY HEARD ME ON
THE RADIO THEY READ THE BOOK A
SOLID DOCUMENTARY -- DATE THEY
WANTED TO FIND OUT HOW WE WERE
TO ACHIEVING SUCCESS.
AND SOLD A I BASICALLY TAUGHT
THEM THE PRESCRIPTION SO NOW
USING YOUR WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE -- PLEASE TAKE THE
TRAINING IT'S IT'S IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS IS LIKE.
IT'S REALLY THE KEY TO THE
PRESCRIPTION ONCE YOU ONCE I CAN
TEACH YOU HOW TO DO IT YOU CAN
DO A WHEREVER YOUR ASIAN.
THAT STARTED YOU OUT AND
CONTINUES AND GETTING PROPAGATED.
THERE IS DEFINITELY A VISION --
I BELIEVE IN A WORLD WHERE OUT
INCARCERATION IN A WORLD WITHOUT
VIOLENCE WHICH IS A VISION A
HELL OF A VISION BUT YOU KNOW
THAT I'M WORKING TOWARD DAD AND
ALL I DO IS.
IS IS IS SAVE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
I CAN GET MY HANDS ON IT AND I
ALWAYS SO MY JOB IS TO KEEP
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM FALLING INTO
THE TRAP.
AND THEN MAYBE YOU CAN HANDLE
REMOVE THE TRACKS ONE OF MY
LATEST YOUNG MAN IS A GUY NAME.
IT'S INCREDIBLE USE I MET HIM IN
JAIL WHEN HE WAS.
SIXTEEN A SOUND MOREHOUSE
COLLEGE.
AND I CALL FROM US.
DOING ALL THE CITY HOW HE IS NOW
MY SUPERVISOR IN MY DISTRICT.
IS THE KID THAT ACT THIS WELL
NOW HE IS YOU HEARD A CIGARETTE
BRAND THAT JUST HAPPENED.
THAT'S MY KID RIGHT.
SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS HE'S NOW
REMOVING THE TRAPS BUT ALL OF
THIS IS POSSIBLE IF IN FACT YOU
KNOW HOW TO TAKE ALL OF THAT
TOWN.
AND I GOT SOME NEWS OR YOU'LL.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE I KNOW WITH
THEIR I KNOW WAS THERE EDU ABLE
TO ON EARTH IT OR OR YOU'RE NOT
THAT THEM FALLING TO DRESS IN
THE FIRST PLACE THANK YOU DOCTOR
MARCIA -- I WISH WE HAD TIME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I'VE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TESTIFYING TODAY AND WORK WILL
STAY IN CONTACT I WANNA HEAR
MORE THOSE STORIES OF THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
SO I WILL LIKE TO BRING UP --
OUR FIRST PANEL.
AN OVERVIEW IMPORTANCE OF
EFFECTIVE EDUCATORS -- INVITE
JEFF FREY THIS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
AND ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR.
OF FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
DOCTOR MARK WITH A GRIN NOTE
[inaudible]
SHARE.
SHAILA SHIRE.
JUST [inaudible]
THIS WEEK.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
WHO WOULD LIKE?
I I HAD YOUR NAME FIRST SO OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT WORKS AS WHEN
THE CHECK AND AND THE FIRST ONE
I THINK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- FOR HAVING
THIS PANEL AND HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION -- AND I WENT THINK
THE THE FULL COMMITTEE -- ALSO --
FOR CONTINUING THIS DISCUSSION.
I APOLOGIZE -- I'M VERY PROUD AS
A LEADER OF SAFETY TO HAVE A
TASK FORCE THIS TASK FORCE
REPORT.
IS AVAILABLE OVER ON THE SIDE I
THINK IT WAS HANDED OUT -- IF I
THINK EVERYBODY HAS -- ONE AND
IS BE ABLE TO SHARE OUR WORK
THAT WE'RE WE'RE DOING TO BE
ABLE TO FOCUS TO IN THE SCHOOL
PRISON PIPELINE AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATIONAL
JUSTICE FOR BLACK MALES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OUR
NATIONAL UNION A HAVE TO HAVE A
TASK FORCE AND THEN PUBLISHED A
REPORT I SAT ON THAT TASK FORCE
WITH A FEW OTHER PEOPLE FROM
CALIFORNIA SINCE IT WAS A
NATIONAL -- EFFORT -- AND IT WAS
RECLAIMING THE PROMISE OF RACIAL
EQUITY IN EDUCATION.
ECONOMIC IN CRIMINAL JUSTICES --
IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT ESTABLISHED A BROAD FRAMEWORK --
SOME OF THAT -- YOU'RE
DISCUSSING A MINUTE MUCH OF THAT
YOU'RE DISCUSSING HERE ON THIS
PANEL AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT THE
ASSEMBLY -- AND THE AND THE
LEGISLATURE WILL COMPASS AND IT
IS -- EMONA HERE -- BETTER
FACING THE INEQUALITIES FACING
THE BLACK MALES OF ALL AGES --
WITH THAT UNDERSTAND AND IT
WOULD BE UP TO STATE FEDERATIONS
AND LOCAL UNIONS TO CONTINUE
THAT EFFORT.
AS A LEADER OF CFT NOT PRESIDENT
AT THE TIME -- AND AS A LEADER
OF SAFETY I DEMANDED TO CREATE A
SPACE FOR THAT TASK FORCE TO
HAPPEN CALIFORNIA IN C. F. T. --
I DIDN'T LEAD THE EFFORT BECAUSE
I WANTED THEY'LL EFFORT LED BY
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS -- I DON'T
WANT TO DRIVE THE OUTCOME I
DON'T WANT TO DRIVE -- THIS IS
THE DISCUSSION OR THE PROCESS I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WAS AN OPEN SPACE FOR OUR
MEMBERS -- A DIVERSE GROUP OF
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE THAT.
OUT THEY DECIDED TO FOCUS JUST
ON EDUCATION SO IN CALIFORNIA WE
TOOK THE THE CRIMINAL ECONOMIC
AND EDUCATION THE NATIONAL LEVEL
WITH FOCUS JUST ON THE EDUCATION
PART OF IT -- AND WE ALSO ONE OF
THE FIRST DISCUSSIONS WHAT WE
HAD WAS WHY ARE WE JUST FOCUSING
ON BLACK MALES.
I THINK THAT THAT'S AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION ANY
TIME WE JUST HAVE A REPORT
AROUND JUST BLACK MALES -- OUR
DISCUSSION FOCUSED ON LOOKING AT
ALL THE METRICS.
BLACK MALES HAVE THE WORST
METRICS OF ANY GRADUATION PRISON
RATES OF ECONOMIC -- AND THAT'S
WHY WE WANT TO FOCUS THE SECOND
THING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE AND
BE CLEAR ON IS THIS ARE THE
SOLUTIONS ARE USUALLY
INTERSECTIONAL -- IN WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS -- AN EXAMPLE THAT
WE'RE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN THERE WAS A LOT OF PASSED
THE CURBS CORNER OF CROSS
STREETS?
THE SLOPE DOWN FOR PEOPLE IN
WHEELCHAIRS IT APPLIED TO PEOPLE
AND CANES PEOPLE THAT MAYBE
BLIND PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE.
MULTIPLE A CHILD CARE -- A
CARRIAGE -- THERE ARE MULTIPLE
SOLUTIONS AT A SOLID BUT WAS
FOCUSED ON ONE GROUP AND THAT'S
WHERE I TALK ABOUT THE INTEREST
ACT INTERSECTIONAL SOLUTIONS ON
THAT COME OUT OF OUR REPORT THAT
WE BELIEVE OUR PRIDE.
ALMOND DON'T JUST FOCUS ON BLACK
MALES WE FOCUSED ON BLACK MALES
BUT THE SOLUTIONS SOLVE MANY
THINGS -- SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
GET TO TWO OF OUR FOUR OF
PRIORITIES -- OUR PRIORITIES ARE
FOCUSED IN FOUR AREAS
DIVERSIFYING AND SPECIFICALLY A
DIVERSIFYING WITH BLACK MALES --
ARE TEACHING AND CLASSIFIED
FORCE -- EDUCATING ALL OF OUR
TEACHING AND CLASSIFIED OF FOLKS
IN.
IN DIVERSITY AND CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY -- I'LL GET TO THAT
ALSO THAT NOT WHAT I'M NOT GOING
TO TALK ABOUT TODAY BUT C. T. --
CAREER TECHNICAL OPPORTUNITIES --
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE THOSE OF
THE FOUR BASIC POINTS -- I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE FIRST --
TWO SO OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
THAT CAME OUT OF THIS REPORT WAS
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS TO INTENTIONALLY.
HELP IDENTIFY RECRUIT DEVELOP
AND RETAIN BLACKMAIL EDUCATORS --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH YOU WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- BILLS LEGISLATION
ANYTHING WE CAN PASS ON OR
ANYTHING.
WE CAN DO WITH OTHER GROUPS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS AND HELP
IDENTIFY FUNDS A CREATE PROGRAMS
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF BLACK MALES BECOME
EDUCATORS.
IS A COMMITMENT THAT SEE IF TEAM
MEMBERS AND LEADERS SEE IS A
PRIORITY FOR ORGANIZATION AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
RECRUITING DEVELOPING RETAINING
MORE BLACK MALE EDUCATORS AS A
STARTING POINT FOR IMPROVING
OUTCOMES NOT ONLY FOR BLACK MALE
STUDENTS.
BUT AS RESEARCH APPROACH HAS
PROVEN FOR ALL STUDENTS.
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT DEARTH OF
BLACKMAIL EDUCATORS MUST BE A
CRITICAL ASPECT OF ANY PLAN TO
DISMANTLE THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
AND IT'S DEADLY.
DEADLY DESPERATE IMPACTS ON SOME
BLACK STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING AT THE
BEGINNING AND IT'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING WE TALK ABOUT IS
FINANCE ARE ECONOMIC.
REASONINGS BUT I COULD TELL YOU.
THAT FROM CFCS PERSPECTIVE THAT
EVEN IF THE COST MORE.
IN THE PRISON THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE WE WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT -- I I THINK
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO SELL THAT
IT'S CHEAPER TO EDUCATE THEM
THEIR CAR STRAIGHT.
BUT IT'S HUMANE AND THAT TO US
IS MORE IMPORTANT -- NOT TO
DIMINISH THE RATIONALE THAT
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO CONVINCE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT NOT ON
NECESSARY ON THE SAME PAGE --
ONE OF THINGS I WANT TO POINT
OUT BECAUSE WE HAD OUR TASK
FORCE BE REVIEWED BY -- MANY
PEERS -- THAT HAVE DONE THIS AS
WELL AS STUDENTS WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE WE THERE WERE CERTAIN
PEOPLE ON THE THE PANEL THE TASK
FORCE THAT WANTED TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS.
BLACK MALE STUDENTS COULD
RESPOND TO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WE HAD IS WHEN DID YOU FIRST
HAVE A TEACHER WHO IS BLACK MALE.
A BLACK MAN AND WHAT DID IT MEAN
FOR YOU. SIX REYES SAID I WOULD
LIKE MORE BLACK MALE TEACHERS
THEY'VE BEEN IN OUR SHOES THEIR
COMPREHENSION LEVEL OF US IS
HIGHER.
ANOTHER ONE SAID THIS YEAR I'M A
SOPHOMORE HE CALLED US KINGS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THERE ARE MANY.
EXAMPLES OF THAT IN THE REPORT --
IT WAS.
HEART WRENCHING I SHOULD SAY --
SADLY ONLY 1% OF TEACHING
CALIFORNIA BLACK MALES RESEARCH
CONDUCTED FOR OUR UNIONS RACIAL
JUSTICE PLAN FOUND AT WHITE MALE
STUDENTS. TO WHITE MALE TEACHER
WAS ABOUT. FIFTEEN TO ONE FOR
BLACK MALE STUDENTS IT WAS.
FIFTY FOUR TO ONE AND CONTINUE
WITH THE INTERSECTION ALLERGY
LATINO MALES IT WAS SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ONE I'M SO WE KNOW
THERE'S A BIGGER ISSUE -- BUT
AGAIN WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE ONE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW THE GROSS
DISPARITY SCREAMS FOR URGENT
ATTENTION.
THE SECOND OUR FOCUS WAS TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY RACIAL
EQUITY AND UNCONSCIOUS BIAS ALL
THREE ISSUES.
IT KEEPS CHANGING AND AND
FLOWING -- BIAS TRAINING THAT
HELPS TEACHERS AND OTHER SCHOOL
STAFF UNDERSTAND THEIR OWN
PERSONAL BIAS.
TEACHERS SUCH AS ME THAT LOOK
LIKE ME WE NEED CONTINUING TRAIN
I AM LEARNING ALL THE TIME I
WENT RECENTLY TO DALIO THAT'S
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
LATINO ELECTED AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS CONFERENCES LAST
WEEKEND.
AND THE TRAINING THAT I SAW
SPECIFICALLY ON THE TALK SOON.
TOXICITY OF PEOPLE'S LIVES IF
THEY DON'T HAVE ONE PERSON
CARING FOR THEM -- DOESN'T TURN
IT CANNOT TURN AROUND THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
DAMAGE THAT OCCURS -- WHEN YOU
HAVE DEVASTATING SITUATIONS AS A
VERY YOUNG CHILD -- AND IT'S
THIS TYPE OF SITUATION AND
SOLUTION THAT DOES HELP THAT
THAT RAISES THE AWARENESS OF NOT
ONLY SOMEONE THAT LOOKS LIKE YOU
BUT SOMEONE IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU TO HELP OUT -- AND THAT'S
THAT IS THE SECOND THING THAT
WERE FOCUSING ON ANOTHER QUOTE
IN QUESTION TO THE STUDENTS WHAT
SHOULD TEACHERS BE LEARNING TO
EFFECTIVELY TEACH BLACK STUDENTS.
ONE WORK ONE STUDENT RESPONDED I
HAVE A GOOD GPA I COME TO SCHOOL
AND WE SOME DAYS AND THEY DON'T
ASK WHY.
ANOTHER SAID YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS WITH KIDS
QUOTE KIDS BEFORE YOU CAN
CONTROL THEIR LIFE WE DON'T WANT
TO BE CONTROLLED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
MANAGERS.
SORRY -- THAT WAS NOT IN THE
QUOTE LET ALONE BEING CONTROLLED
BY SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW YOU --
AS EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS WE ARE ALL
COMMITTED TO ANSWERING ARE
CALLING TO HELP OUR STUDENTS TO
GROW TO SUCCEED AND TO LEAD.
THAT'S WHY I BECAME A TEACHER IN
THE FIRST PLACE -- WE CANNOT
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL WITHOUT
TEARING DOWN THE OP SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE BEEN BACKED INTO THE U. S.
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY BLACK MALE
STUDENTS.
SINCE OUR NATION'S FOUNDING.
RACIAL EQUITY FOCUSED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IS
NEEDED TO HELP ALL EDUCATORS
RISE TO THAT CHALLENGE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE EXAMPLES OF PROGRAMS
LATER IN YOUR PRESENTATION -- OF
MANY PEOPLE -- I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU -- PERSONALLY AND OF THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE AND WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT SEE IF HE'S
COMMITTED ON WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO BEING INCREASE.
SPECIFICALLY THESE TWO AREAS ARE
JUST AND THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
S..
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MARQUITA GORNO SHIRE
I'M THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR EDUCATOR
PREPARATION OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
IN MY ROLE I HAVE PRIVILEGE OF
DEVELOPING AND SUPPORTING
EDUCATOR PREPARATION PROGRAMS
ALONG SIDE MY DEAN AND FACULTY
CAL COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
THROUGHOUT THE CSU EDUCATOR
PREPARATIONS PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND EXCELLENCE IN
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
GRADUATES ARE PREPARED ON DAY.
ONE AS BEGINNING TEACHERS TO
WORK WITH ALL DIVERSE LEARNERS
IN CALIFORNIA THE CSU PREPARES
MORE THAN -- HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS PRESCHOOL
THROUGH TWELFTH AT APPROXIMATELY
8210% OF THE NATION'S TEACHERS
GRADUATE FROM THE CSU.
OUR FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS
WORK CLOSELY WITH LOCAL SCHOOL
SYSTEMS TO PREPARE EDUCATORS WHO
DEMONSTRATE THE SKILLS AND
ABILITIES THAT DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY.
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE TEACHING
THAT ENSURES THAT ALL PK TWELVE
STUDENTS ARE ACADEMICALLY
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER.
BUT CRITICAL PILL PILLAR OF THE
CSU SYSTEM WIDE STUDENT SUCCESS
INITIATIVES GRADUATION EDITION
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ADDITIONALLY OUR PROGRAMS REPAIR
TEACHERS COUNSELORS AND LEADERS
WHO CAN WORK TOGETHER ALONGSIDE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. TO
DISRUPT SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES IN
EDUCATION AND PROVE THAT THE
PROLIFERATION OF THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION THE
PROBLEM THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE IS THAT A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
INCLUDING THOSE WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBT Q. THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
AND OR ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
ARE PLACED INTO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RESULTING FROM MINOR SCHOOL
INFRACTIONS AND DISCIPLINARY
MATTERS OFTENTIMES EDUCATORS
SUBJECT THE STUDENTS TO HARSHER
PUNISHMENTS THAN THEIR WHITE
PEERS FOR THE SAME BEHAVIORS.
A RECENT ANY A RESOLUTION STATED
SCHOOLS MUST BE SAFE AND
WELCOMING PLACES FOR ALL
STUDENTS DISCRIMINATORY TOWARD
NON AND FOCUS ON EDUCATIONAL
PRACTICES THAT REACH THE WHOLE
CHILD.
FURTHER DISCIPLINARY PRINT
POLICIES MUST EMPHASIZE
PREVENTION AND REHABILITATION
OVER PUNISHMENT.
WELL MY COMMENTS TODAY FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON TEACHER PREPARATION
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
PROJECT REBOUND IS A SYSTEM WIDE
SPECIAL ADMISSION PROGRAMS FOCUS
ON SUPPORTING THE TRANSITION.
AND ACCLAMATION OF FORMALLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH INTO COLLEGE.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THREE AREAS
OF BEST PRACTICES TO ADDRESS THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
RECRUITMENT MULTIPLE PATHWAYS
INTO TEACHING AND CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION.
RECRUITMENT OF STRONG AND
DIVERSE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
TEACHERS COUNSELORS AND LEADERS
WHO REFLECT THE COMMUNITY THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY WILL
SERVE.
AS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE CSU
AND HELPS TO MITIGATE THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE.
NATIONAL BEST PRACTICES AND THE
PROFESSIONAL LITERATURE SUPPORT
THE INFO ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
A DIVERSE TEACHING FORCE.
CLOSING MIKE AND SOCIAL BENEFITS
TEACHERS OF COLOR SERVICE STRONG
ROLE MODELS BECAUSE OF STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THEY OFTEN HAVE
HIGHER EXPECTATIONS THAN THEIR
PEERS FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE OFTEN DEVELOP MORE TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STUDENTS AND
THEY'RE OFTEN BETTER ABLE TO
MITIGATE TENSIONS ARISING FROM
RACIS.
TEACHER DIVERSITY WILL ALSO
IMPROVE THE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE IS A WHITE STUDENTS
WHO OFTEN MISS OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN FROM THE CULTURALLY
DIVERSE DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES
THAT NON WHITE TEACHERS BRING TO
THE CLASSROOM.
THE CHRONIC TEACHER SHORTAGE
THAT EXIST IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THE NATION HAS HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND POOR
STUDENTS.
DATA FROM THE OFFICE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS INDICATE THAT DISTRICTS
THAT SERVE MORE STUDENTS OF
COLOR EMPLOYED ABOUT FOR MORE
TIME FOUR TIMES MORE TEACHERS
THAT ARE NOT FULLY CERTIFIED.
SIMILARLY STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE ALSO MORE
LIKELY TO BE TAUGHT BY
UNDERPREPARED.
THAT'S IT IS CRITICAL TO ADDRESS
THE TEACHER SHORTAGE IN MULTIPLE
WAYS.
THROUGHOUT OUR SYSTEM THERE
ESTABLISH PIPELINE PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION ACROSS THE SECONDS
INTO OUR TEACHER CREDENTIAL
PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE RECRUITMENT EFFORTS TO
BEGIN AS EARLY AS MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL AND STRATEGIES FOCUS
ON FRESHMAN TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND POST BACCALAUREATE STUDENTS
AND CAREER CHANGERS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AT ALLOCATED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GRANTS FOR
FOUR YEAR INTEGRATED TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS WHICH IS A
PATHWAY FOR FRESHMEN WHO KNOW AT
THE VERY BEGINNING THAT THEY
WANT TO BE A TEACHER.
THIS SUPPORT RESULTED IN TWENTY
SIX NEW PROGRAMS IN THE CSU.
IN REGARDS TO CREEK CONSTRUCTION
WE PREPARE TEACHERS COUNSELORS
LEADERS WHO UNDERSTAND AND
DEMONSTRATE BEST PRACTICES IN
TEACHER EDUCATION.
OUR PROGRAMS ARE BASED UPON THE
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS AND
TEACHING PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS WHICH REQUIRE
BEGINNING TEACHERS TO
DEMONSTRATE THE KNOWLEDGE SKILLS
AND ABILITIES TO PROVIDE SAFE.
HEALTHY AND SUPPORTIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF EACH AND EVERY LEARNER.
PREPARATION PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING DEEP CONTENT
KNOWLEDGE IN CANDIDATES RELATED
TO LITERACY MATHEMATICS AND
OTHER CORE SUBJECT AREAS SO THAT
OUR CANDIDATES ARE PREPARED ON
DAY ONE TO TEACH A CALIFORNIA
COMMON CORE STATE STANDARDS AND
THE NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS.
SECOND OUR PROGRAMS EMPHASIZE
THE WELL BEING OF THE WHOLE
STUDENT.
WHOSE SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES
ADDRESSED THROUGH INSTRUCTION ON
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE PEDAGOGY.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION THAT
SUPPORT SUCH PRACTICES CAN HELP
TO MILLER EIGHT DISPARITIES AND
HOW STUDENTS ARE DISCIPLINE.
THIRD OUR FACULTY WORK WAS SO
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARTNERS TO
DESIGN AND DELIVER MEANINGFUL
CLINICAL EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
RESIDENCIES.
THE CSU NEW GENERATION OF
EDUCATION AS EDUCATORS
INITIATIVE IN GI.
HAS RESULTED IN POWERFUL ANTI
PARTNERSHIPS THAT BEGIN WITH A
SHARED VISION OF EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTION.
COLLABORATION ON DEFINING
PRIORITIZE SKILLS FOR A
CANDIDATES PROVISION OF HIGH
QUALITY OPPORTUNITIES TO
DEMONSTRATE THESE SKILLS
SUPPORTED BY EXPERIENCED TEACHER
MENTORS.
AND USE OF DATA TO DRIVE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
FINALLY OUR PROGRAMS REPAIR
CANDIDATES TO COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER EDUCATORS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS WITHIN A WHOLE SCHOOL
REFORM MODEL THE CALIFORNIA
MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK
ALIGNS ACADEMIC BEHAVIORAL AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND A
FULLY INTEGRATED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
STUDENTS.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN UNEQUIVOCALLY THAT
STUDENTS OF COLOR SUSPENDED AND
EXPELLED A DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGHER RATES THAN THEIR WHITE
PEERS.
WHICH IS RESULTED IN EDUCATORS
BOTH AT THE PRE SERVICE AS WELL
AS IN SERVICE LEVELS AS MY
COLLEAGUE STRESS TO ASSESS
SCHOOL DISCIPLINE PRACTICES TO
ENSURE SAFE AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS.
WE KNOW THE MORE TIME STUDENTS
SPEND OUT OF THE CLASSROOM THE
MORE THEY LOSE THEIR SENSE OF
CONNECTION TO THE SCHOOL.
THIS RESULTS IN INCREASED RATES
OF TRUANCY CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
AND ANTI SOCIAL BEHAVIOR WHICH
IN TURN EXACERBATES EQUITY GAP
AND INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
STUDENTS LEAVING SCHOOL.
IN THE CSU WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CHANGING THIS TRAJECTORY TO THE
PRACTICES ABOUT.
HOW I HAVE OUTLINED TODAY?
SO THAT EACH AND EVERY STUDENT
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE AND BECOME A
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF HER
COMMUNITY.
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US TO
PREPARE EDUCATORS I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INTEREST IN YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS CRITICAL
TOPIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UP UNTIL WHAT IT SO
PART OF MY PARTY WHERE WILL LIKE
THIS THE COMMITTEE TO GET TO AN
IN AND OUT TO IT THIS WAY --
WHAT WHEN MY SON WAS -- SEVEN IN
FIRST GRADE -- BUT IT.
THE PRINCIPAL HIS TEACHER AND
HIS MOTHER WAS A TEACHER HAD
DECIDED.
DADDY HE WAS WILLFULLY DEFINE.
AND THEY BROUGHT ME IN TO TALK
TO ME ABOUT NEXT STEPS -- THE
FIRST THING THEY TALKED TO ME
ABOUT THE IF HE ACTED A CERTAIN
WAY WOULD BE SUSPENDED.
A WHICH I PUSH BACK AND SAID THE
REASON YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
BECAUSE MY SON IS THE DESCENDANT
OF KINGS AND QUEENS FROM AFRICA
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DEAL WITH A STRONG BLACK MAN --
THEY LIKE THAT ANSWER
[inaudible]
IT DIDN'T.
TRY TO TELL ME MY SON WAS EIGHTY
DE.
UM IF YOU KNOW ME FROM THIS
MORNING HE'S NOT AT T. JUST
REALLY HYPER LIKE IS THAT -- AND
SO -- I KIND OF PUSHED BACK EVEN
HARDER ON THAT.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT EXPELLING
HIM.
AND THEN I HEARD SOMEONE SAY
THAT THEY WANT TO PUT HIM ON
REDLANDS.
WHAT KIND OF SNACKS?
AND I SAID SOME NON PROFESSIONAL
WORDS.
WHERE THEY HAD TO CALL THE
RESOURCE OFFICERS AND SCHOOL
POLICE TO ESCORT ME OUT OF THAT
ROOM -- WE WORKED IT OUT AND WE
WE GOT TO A PLACE TO WHERE HE
WAS ABLE TO GET THROUGH THAT.
THE NEXT YEAR MY SON HAD IT
AFTER AMERICAN MALE TEACHER WITH
DREADLOCKS.
AND HE BECAME A STRAIGHT A
STUDENT.
ON A BENCH THE GRADUATED FROM
MOREHOUSE WITH A DEGREE IN
BIOLOGY AND MATH AND HE'S NEVER
LOOK BACK AND HE'S NOW A TEACHER
IN LA UNIFIED WHICH I'LL.
TALK ABOUT THAT.
FIASCO -- TO BUT THERE'S YES MY
QUESTION IS IN HOPEFULLY GET US --
TO THE RESOURCES.
AND THE TEACHERS ARE GIVING.
AS TOOLS TO DEAL WITH -- SO
QUOTE WE GOT RESIDENTS ARE WITH
YOU TO FIND AND HOPEFULLY ONE
DAY WE'LL GET RID OF THE TERM AT
RISK AND CALL THEM AT PROMISE
BECAUSE THESE KIDS ARE RISK
DECIDED OR PROMISES OF FUTURE --
YOU'RE ONLY GIVEN SO MANY TOOLS
AND SOME OF IT ENDS UP WITH
REDLANDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WHEN YOU
TRAINING THESE YOUNG TEACHERS
WHAT TOOLS YOU KNOW DO YOU ARE
WE NOW TO RUN DE ESCALATION AND
WE DON'T WHAT A WEEK.
AND IF AND IF WE DO NEED TO
CHANGE THE WAY WE WE GET.
TOOLS TO DIFFERENT.
WHETHER TEACHER ON THE JOB OR
WERE YOU TRAINING NOW -- WHAT
KIND OF BUDGET ASK WOULD THAT BE
WHAT IS THAT IS THAT A?
IS THAT DO WE HAVE TO CHANGE
EDUCATION CODE IS THAT SO I MEAN
WHAT
WOULD YOU THINK I KNOW THIS IS
LIKE COMING OUT OF NOWHERE BUT
THINK IF I HAD.
I COULD GIVE YOU A BLANK CHECK
AND YOU COULD JUST DECIDE WHICH
ONE TO TO TAKE ARM THE TEACHERS
SO THEY CAN DO THIS JOB A LOT
BETTER.
MATT MASS ART THERE.
I MENTION THE MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT THAT'S A
FANCY NAME FOR A NEW SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA FOR HOW WE ARE
STRUCTURING -- SCHOOLS AND IT'S
BRINGING ALL MEMBERS OF THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY TEACHERS
COUNSELORS LEADERS FAMILIES
TOGETHER. TO DEVELOP INSTRUCTION
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF ALL
STUDENTS SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT A
PYRAMID AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
PYRAMID IS JUST GOOD TEACHING
FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AND HAND AS YOU MOVE UP IN THE
PERIOD THE IN THE PYRAMID YOU
NEED MORE SUPPORTS YOU MAY NEED
SOME DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROGRAMS
YOU MAY NEED -- AND A LITERACY
COACH TO COME IN YOU MAY NEED A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER TO
COME IN YOU MAY NEED A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST TO COME IN.
AND DO PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
RELATED TO RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THAT
SYSTEM IF YOU WERE TO GIVE ME A
BLANK CHECK.
I WOULD EXPAND THAT SYSTEM INTO
PRE SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES AND IN
SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT
ALL OF OUR FACULTY HAVE THE
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE TO WORK
WITHIN THE SYSTEM AND TO WORK
WITH EACH OTHER. ONE OF THE
AREAS OF EMPHASIS IN THE C.
ISSUES ON COOPERATION BECAUSE A
SINGLE TEACHER CANNOT DO IT BY
HERSELF AND WE KNOW THAT.
SO HOW DO WE BUILD IN SUPPORT
FOR TEACHERS TO WORK TOGETHER
AGAIN ALONGSIDE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. TO GET WHAT EACH
AND EVERY LEARNER NEEDS THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD DO WITHOUT BLANK
CHECK -- OR GIVE THEM THE FAX TO
ASK FOR TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS MORE.
THAT'S A STARTING POINT -- AND
AS WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
WHAT I HEAR WHEN SHE SAYS THAT
IS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS IN THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD THESE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING
MULTIPLE RESOURCES?
AND IT CAN JUST BE FOR THE
STUDENTS IT ALSO SB FOR THE
FAMILIES -- BECAUSE THERE ARE
THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T CONTROL
THEIR OUTSIDE OF THE SCHOOL TIME
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT JUST THE
TEACHER IT HAS TO BE.
ALL OF THESE RESOURCES THAT ARE
PROVIDED MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
COUNSELING RESOURCES -- EVEN
SITE YOU KNOW.
DOCTOR PHYSICAL RESOURCES -- IN
THAT THAT IS KIND OF CHANGING
THE STRUCTURE AND AND LOOK OF
OUR SCHOOLS INTO COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS -- SO THEY'RE ALL TYPES
OF RESOURCES THERE -- THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT -- WHICH IS.
PROBABLY.
MORE FINER EASIER TO DO OR THE
ART AS WE TALKED ABOUT THE THE
TRAINING OF THE STAFF THE CHEN
IN THE EDUCATION WHEN I WAS A
TEACHER AS A HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER.
BUT I PUSHED TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES I HAD NO BACKGROUND TO
DO THIS I KNEW I WANTED TO DO
THIS NOR WERE THERE ANY
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO ME BY THIS
SMALL SCHOOL CARPINTERIA -- TO
DO IT IS AND I WAS TOLD THE LAST
DAY OF BEFORE THE SPRING
SEMESTER.
AS THE HEAD BASKETBALL COACH IN
THE BILL MIDDLE OF BASKETBALL
SEASON -- TOLD HAD NEW
CURRICULUM TO TEACH THAT I DID
ASK FOR BUT WASN'T PREPARED TO
DO ARM AND I TRIED MY BEST TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THE STUDENTS --
BUT THAT TRAINING NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO THE TEACHERS AND THE
IMPACT IS WELL THAT'S ONE PLACE
TO START TO HELP OUT WITH THIS --
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE AND THE
MONEY THE BIG MONEY QUESTION OR
ISSUE OR THESE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
WITH ALL THESE RESOURCES AND
NEED TO BE PROVIDED TO THE
STUDENT.
SO THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
AVOID -- THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S REALLY GOING.
DO WE ALSO NEED TO DO A POLICY.
MAYBE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY
SAY YES I BELIEVE IN THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT OTHERS MAY SAY.
I DON'T NEED IT IS THAT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE MAKE POLICY PRE
ENTIRE STATE.
WE BUDGET FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
AND AND THIS BIG STATE NOT
EVERYBODY BUYS IN.
RIGHT TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT
IT I THINK EVERY DISTRICT NEEDS
TO BUY IT.
SO IS THAT ALSO POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS.
BECAUSE THE POLICY CONSIDERATION
AYE AYE -- DEFER TO MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF
WHAT WORKS BEST WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND HOW ARE THEY
DEFINING THIS IDEA OF A
COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
MASS FOR ONE MORE THING SINCE
YOU.
YOUR BOOK.
IF AND IT WAS MENTIONED.
EARLIER -- BY THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS AND IT'S ABOUT
RECRUITING MORE TEACHERS OF
COLOR TO WORK IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
SO -- I KNOW WE HAVE A
FORGIVABLE LOAN PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN APPROVED THIS YEAR BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
WE NEED MORE OF THAT WE NEED
SERVICE SCHOLARSHIP -- FOR OUR
CANDIDATES WE NEED FINANCE
SCHOLARSHIP SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU LOOK IN TODAY'S NEWSPAPER
THE CSU OF JUST MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT A SERVICE
SCHOLARSHIP WHEN THE BECHTEL
FOUNDATION TO AWARD SCHOLARSHIPS.
TO STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING TO
WORK AT HIGH NEED SCHOOLS AND SO
WE HAVE THREE POINT TWO MILLION
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN TO THE CSU TO
SUPPORT THREE HUNDRED CANDIDATES.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND HIGH NEED SCHOOLS A
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH.
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED TO
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM SO WE THINK
ABOUT SUPPORT AT THE BEGINNING
WAS TO THINK ABOUT SUPPORT
DURING A STUDENT DURING A
CANDIDATES PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE FORGIVABLE LOAN
PROGRAMS -- AGAIN FOCUS TARGETED
ON TEACHERS WHO ARE WILLING TO
WORK IN HIGH NEED AREAS.
MATH SCIENCE SPECIAL EDUCATION
BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A QUESTION
COULD I I I MAY ADD IN THERE.
HOUSING SUBSIDY MIGHT GET A
WHOLE LOT OF TEACHERS IT
ABSOLUTELY WAS.
THAT WAS IN MY NOTES I WAS IN MY
BACK POCKET.
I DO AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT.
STRUCTURAL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
CREATING A SYSTEM WE'RE YOUR
TRAINING TEACHERS TEACHING
TEACHERS ABOUT THE BIGGER
ASPECTS OF WHAT IT IS BUT WHAT I
WORRY ABOUT IS WE KEEP.
THROWING MORE AND MORE
OBLIGATION ON OUR TEACHERS WHO
WANT TO GO AND TEACH.
WHERE THE SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCIES WHERE THE HEALTH
SERVICES AGENCIES?
FROM THIS NOTION OF A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL.
BECAUSE IF IF THE IF THE SCHOOLS
ARE NOW IT IS A GREAT NOTION.
BUT WE HAVE TO COMPLETE THE
PICTURE.
SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
TRAINING TO TEACHERS THAT WERE
NOT TURNING THEM INTO SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT WERE NOT TURNING
THEM INTO HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
INTO.
THOSE COMPONENTS HAVE TO COME IN
AS WELL.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
WERE TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF
BECAUSE WHEN THE PROBLEMS THAT I
HAVE HERE IS WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT THE BACK AT WERE JUST
WE WERE TRYING TO REFORM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHICH IS THE SYSTEM WE SHOULD
EVEN HAVE.
WHICH I TO REFORM THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM WHICH IS A SYSTEM
WE SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE.
ALL OF THIS GOES POINTS BACK.
TO SUPPORTS FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES SO THAT IS KIDS COME
INTO THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
THEY THEY ARE PREPARED TO LEARN
AND TO DO THAT WORK AS A STUDENT.
AND YET WE HAVE A WHOLE SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS THEM IN SUPPORT
THE TEACHERS IN SUPPORT LET'S
TEACHERS KIND OF DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO FOR BRING ALL OF
THESE COMPONENTS TO BEAR.
SO THAT WE CAN SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS IN THE FAMILY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA SPOKE.
WITH ALL THE PRO FOR THE CHILD
WITHOUT DEALING WITH THAT FAMILY
AND THAT COMMUNITY AND AND WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM.
SO HOW DO WE RE THINK THIS
SYSTEM SO THAT WE HAVE ALL OF
THOSE COMPONENTS THERE AND WHEN
WE DON'T JUST KEEP PUTTING THIS
ON ON THE TEACHERS.
WELL -- AS A HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER.
I BECAME A HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER NOT.
I TOOK MATH BECAUSE IT WAS EASY
FOR ME NOT BECAUSE I WANTED TO
TEACH IT I WANTED TO HELP
STUDENTS.
SO THE CONCEPT THE TEACHERS WANT
TO TEACH ISN'T IS IS TOO NARROW
TEACHERS WANT TO HELP.
AND I DON'T OBEY I DID WANT AYE
AYE OTHERS AT DISCOUNT YEAH OKAY
BUT I WORRY ABOUT THROWING TOO
MUCH ON THE TO PUBLICATION.
I TEACHERS WHO WANT TO HELP BUT
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR A CLASSROOM
TOO MANY KIDS IN A CLASSROOM
REYES AWAY.
BUT THEY HAVE THAT BROADER
RESPONSIBILITY THEY NEED TO HELP.
THEY CAN'T BE THERE ONE OF THE
THAT A NEXUS HOW ALL THIS WORKS
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
KIDS FOR SO MANY TIMES.
IF WE SET UP A SYSTEM WHERE
PARENTS CAN ABDICATE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE OTHER
PARTS THE SYSTEM ARE OPERATING
IN SILOS AND NOT SUPPORTING THIS
FUNCTION.
MORE AND MORE THAN FALLS ONTO
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
TEACHER FOR HOME WE HAVE
NECESSARILY HAVE THE TOOLS FOR
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE A
FORTY TO GO SOLVE ALL THESE
PROBLEMS IN AND I AGREE THERE
WILL THERE IS A LOT -- HANDED
DOWN ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS IS THE OVER
ACADEMIA FOCUS.
AND THE SCHOOLS -- THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I LEFT THE
CLASSROOM WAS BECAUSE I HAD LAST
TIME TO WORK WITH THE STUDENTS
AND HAD TO FOCUS ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES AND HAD TO
FOCUS BECAUSE AS A MATH TEACHER.
AND I WAS THERE WHEN THE HIGH
SCHOOL EXIT EXAM WAS PASSED --
AND THERE WAS SO MUCH EMPHASIS
THE OTHER THING IS NOT TO FORGET
THE CLASSIFIED AS WELL BECAUSE
THE CLASSIFIED HAVE A AS HAVING
ACTUAL VESTED ADULTS ON CAMPUS
WHETHER THEY'RE THE JANITORS TO
THE SECRETARIES.
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE STUDENTS
DAY TODAY I KNOW SO MANY
CLASSIFIED THAT THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE ACTUALLY COUNSELING THE
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT LOOK MORE LIKE THE
STUDENTS -- IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION SAID THERE THAT'S
WHERE THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL COMES
IN -- AS WELL AS ADDING THOSE
RESOURCES TO TAKE AWAY THE
ACTUAL -- LEGITIMATE COUNSELING
FROM THE TEACHER WITH.
TEACHERS WANT TO COUNSEL
STUDENTS BUT NOT IN A CLINICAL
WAY WEEDING CLINICAL COUNSELORS
THERE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DEMAND AN AD -- SO I
THINK WE AGREE ON MOST OF THE
THINGS I WAS JUST TRYING -- TO
CLUB MED BUT I JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT ON THE TABLE AND I THINK
IT'S EXCITING IT'S ARE
INTERESTING.
BUT SORT OF BACK TO THE CHAIRS
COMMENT THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO
BE WORKING ON SO THAT WE ARE
BUILDING.
TAKING ALL OF THESE FUNCTIONS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO HELP KIDS
OUT OF THE SILOS.
AND INTO A COORDINATED WAY
YOU'RE SORT OF LAY THAT
GROUNDWORK BUT YOU JUST ONE
PIECE OF THIS.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT A LOT RIGHT
AND THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
FRAMEWORK AND ON YOU HAVE A COPY
OF MY REMARKS.
AND THERE'S SOME RESOURCES AT
THE END THIS IS A SYSTEMIC WAY
TO LOOK AT SUPPORTING ALL
STUDENTS AND ALL TEACHERS
BECAUSE I ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
WE SHOULD NOT PUT THE SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON A SINGLE TEACHER TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF EACH AND EVERY LEARNER
IN HER CLASSROOM WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF FAMILIES AND OTHER
EDUCATORS WHO ARE IN THAT.
SO I I WOULD BE HAPPY TO SEND
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IT'S IN OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
IT'S WORKING -- ACROSS ABOUT
FIFTY DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA SO -- I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO TALK MORE ABOUT THAT AT
ANOTHER TIME YES DEFINITELY AND
AND MAYBE WE CAN.
WHEN WE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE?
THE THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION YES TONY THURMOND
WHO WE WE HAVE A LITTLE.
KNOWLEDGE OF MOVIE CAN
INCORPORATE HIM IN SOME KIND OF
POLICY SLASH BUDGET REQUEST
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
WERE.
WHICH IS WHAT MR STONE IS
GETTING TO LET'S CREATE THIS
LET'S MAKE IT BUT MAKE SURE IT
WORKS.
AND WE WE DON'T TRADE SOMETHING
THAT FALLS ON ITS HEAD BECAUSE
WE WE PUT TOO MUCH AT THE TOP SO.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU BOTH THIS
WAS SIX YEARS WAS IN LIGHTING
THANK YOU.
NOW LIKE TO CALL UP OUR NEXT
PANEL I DID A FINE OBSTACLES.
IN TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE MELANIE
RICHARDSON AND ANGELA WILLIAMS.
GOOD MORNING HI GOOD MORNING
MORNING.
ELECTIONS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
MY TIME IN A START IS GREAT
BECAUSE YOU JUST MENTIONED WITH
RECRUITMENT -- AYE MY NAME IS
MELANIE RICHARDSON AND I'M HUMAN
RESOURCES OFFICER FOR LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
WE ARE THE SECOND LARGEST --
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE STATE
AND WE SERVE ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND SO MY JOB IS TO OVERSEE
RECRUITMENT AND HIRING FOR ALL
OF OUR COLLEGES IN OUR CENTERS.
AND SO I AM THE HOW TO PERSON ON
RECRUITING -- FACULTY AND STAFF
I ALSO SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT OF
OUR BLACK FACULTY AND STAFF
ASSOCIATION AT OVER TWENTY YEARS
OLD AND WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT
OF WORK WITH THREE A DEVELOPMENT
AND RETENTION OF STAFF AND
FACULTY OF COLOR.
I WORK WITH ALL OF OUR AFFINITY
GROUPS SO A P. I. A LATIN X. WE
HAVE A RAINBOW AFFINITY GROUP
THAT WE JUST STARTED.
SO THOSE OF THE PEOPLE THAT I
TALK THAT I WORK WITH AND SO I
WANTED TO DISCUSS THE HOW TO THE
A MODEL.
OF HOW AND WHERE TO RECRUIT.
AND WHAT'S WORKING WHAT NEEDS TO
STOP HAPPENING AND THEN HOW WE
ARE THEN DEVELOPING AND
RETAINING.
THE THESE FACULTY AND STAFF.
SO SO THE TIMING IS RIGHT AND I
HAVE FIVE WHOLE MINUTES.
SO.
SO I AM I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT
THE FIRST THING THAT I FOUND
I'VE BEEN WITH US RULES TWELVE
YEARS WORKING AS CAPACITY SIX
AND A HALF YEARS AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE JUST DON'T KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT FINDING DIVERSE.
CANDIDATES WE TALK ABOUT BLACK
MALE FACULTY A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES JUST UNAWARE OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S THE
FIRST THING THAT WE DON'T THAT
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
DON'T KNOW.
SO -- MY APPROACH HAS BEEN TO
GET WHERE PEOPLE ARE.
AND THEY MORE SPECIFICALLY GET
WERE COMMUNITIES ARE AND THEN
USE OTHER.
PEOPLE AND THEIR AFFINITY GROUPS
TO SPREAD THE WORD FOR EXAMPLE
I'M A MEMBER OF A LOT OF
AFFINITY GROUPS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN -- BLACK WHEN
ORGANIZED POLITICAL ACTION
ZACHMAN SISTER CIRCLE ALL OF
THESE GROUPS AT LARGE IN NUMBER
SO WHEN I SHARE AN OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S BROAD AND THEN I ASK THE
SAME OF MY NATIVE DEAN AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND SHE
SHARES WITH HER COMMUNITY THAT I
HAVE NO ACCESS.
TO SO THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
THINGS I DO AS WELL TO HELP WITH --
AWARENESS RECRUITMENT OF
SPECIFIC GROUPS AND THEN
GENERALLY THERE FOR CAREER
INTACT THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS
THAT WORK AND DON'T WORK BUT WE
WEREN'T WE WEREN'T DOING THAT WE
WEREN'T SCHERING ENOUGH -- I GO
WHERE PEOPLE ARE I HOPE PEOPLE
WHEN I NEED A FARSI FACULTY OR
LONG FACULTY I DON'T PLACE AN AD
I TRY TO GET AND COMMUNITY
THOUGHT WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT
ENOUGH. TO BRING PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE SO YOU CAN'T HAVE FACULTY
OF COLOR AND AND STAFF OF COLOR
IF YOU DON'T THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW IT EXISTS.
AND SO THAT'S A HUGE PART OF
WHAT I DO EVERYDAY I'M VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT THAT AND I
LOOK AT THE OUR ALLY FOR LIKE
WHEN I SPEND THE MONEY OR WHEN I
GO OUT IN THE COMMUNITY.
A WHAT I CHOOSE TO DO AS FAR AS
RECRUITMENT.
SO THAT'S HUGE AND THEN AS THE
PRESIDENT OF BLACK FACULTY AND
STAFF UNDERSTANDING ON WONDERFUL
PEOPLE WITH WONDERFUL WORK AND
FOR TWENTY YEARS THEY THOUGHT
ABOUT.
ME BEFORE I EVEN KNEW ABOUT
LET'S REELS AND SO I AM JUST
TRYING TO PUSH THAT WE DO A LOT
OF STUDENT ENGAGEMENT MOST OF
OUR MEMBERS A STEEP ANY MOSHE.
AND FUENTE AND MESA AND TO THE
WORKING STUDENTS EVERY DAY TO
THIS END.
AND SO WE SUPPORT THEM WE ALSO
DO A LOT OF COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
TO MAKE OPPORTUNITIES UP MAKE
PEOPLE AWARE OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FACULTY AND STAFF AND THEN.
HARD.
HITTING HOW TO MOCK INTERVIEWS
AND EXAMPLE OF HOW PANEL TO RUN
FOR THE PEOPLE CAN COMPETE WHEN
THEY MAKE IT THROUGH THE PROCESS.
FOR LOS REELS WE TRACK EQUITY --
IN OUR DEMOGRAPHICS SO WHO
APPLIED WHO WITH INTERVIEW WHO
WAS HIRED AND SO WE CAN REALLY
GET A FORM AND SENSE OF EACH
COMEDIAN WHAT'S HAPPENING.
SO I THINK THAT TRACKING IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL I'M
HOLDING COMMITTEES ACCOUNTABLE
HOLDEN H. R. ACCOUNTABLE IT'S A
LOT OF THOSE THINGS WE'RE DOING
ON THE FRONT END.
AND THEN THE SUPPORT FOR
EVALUATION AND PROMOTION AND
DEVELOPMENT ON THE BACK IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF FACULTY
AND STAFF WHO GET IN THE SYSTEM.
AND THEY DON'T STAY -- THERE'S
THIS QUOTE THAT SAYS I DON'T
WANT TO GO WHERE I'M TOLERATE
AWARE CELEBRATED HUGE DIFFERENCE
AND SO WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
FIFTY GROUPS TO CREATE THAT
COMMUNITY THAT ENVIRONMENT THAT
WILL KEEP FACULTY SELECTS THAT
RETENTION PIECE.
I'M SO THOSE ARE THAT THAT'S THE
MODEL THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE ARE
DOING THE WORK EVERYDAY LIKE
DOCTOR MARSHALL.
I'M IN FACT HIS HIS TO HIS
SIBLINGS ARE IN OUR LOS REELS
AND THEY ARE AND THEY STARTED
BLACK FACULTY STAFF YEARS AGO.
AFTER THE COMMUNITY IS IS STILL
WORKING ON VERY DIFFERENT ENDS
AND I AM ON THAT FRONT IN I'M
WITH THE RECRUITMENT AND
OVERSEEING THIS PROCESS AND IN
THE TEAM AND STAFF THAT DOES
THAT.
SO THANK YOU YES [inaudible]
MISTER WILLIAMS.
CHAIR MEMBERS DOCTRINES LE
WILLIAM PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES AND
PUBLIC POLICY AT SEXY COLLEGE UC
DAVIS CSU SACRAMENTO.
SEE IF T. L. I SEE A T. LOCAL
TWO TWO SEVEN NINE AT
DESTRUCTIVE READ.
BECAUSE SECOND GO SWIFTLY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE OBSTACLES TO
BECOMING A TEACHER.
HOW HARD IS IT TO BREAK INTO THE
INDUSTRY? TO ART.
RESEARCH HAS DOCUMENTED IN
ADEQUATE TEACHERS SUPPORT UNFAIR
HUMAN RESOURCES RECRUITING AND
HIRING PRACTICES.
AND POOR PERCEPTION OF TEACHING
TO BE THE PRIMARY OBSTACLES TO
BECOMING AN REMAINING A TEACHER.
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE START
STARTING TEACHERS ON A HIGHER
STEP ON THE SALARY SCALE.
PROVIDING MENTORING AND COACHING
SUPPORT BY BLACK TEACHERS
ACTIVELY RECRUITING FROM H. B.
C. USE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND IN
THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
WHEN I GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS I
FACE THESE OBSTACLES BUT I HAD A
BACKGROUND IN PUBLIC POLICY FROM
HIGH SCHOOL INTERNSHIP WITH THE
SOME THE MEMBERS WHEN MORE AND
WANTING TO MAKE DONALD?
THE INTERNSHIP FUEL MY PASSION
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
POLICY WHICH OFFICIALLY LET ME
BACK TO TEACHING.
IN THE INTERIM I EARNED A
MASTER'S AND DOCTORATE DEGREE IN
EDUCATION.
BUT I WAS DIRECTLY RECRUITED
INTO THE TEACHING PROFESSION BY
DOLLY GREEN AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN WHO RAN THE LOS REELS
FACULTY DIVERSITY INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM.
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE WHO
INTENTIONALLY RECRUIT AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND OTHER MINORITY
GROUPS ARE INDISPENSABLE THE F.
B. I. P. PROGRAM SHOULD BE
REPLICATED STATE WHY.
MS GREEN BY INTENTIONALLY
RECRUITING ME THIRTEEN YEARS AGO
WAS ON TO SOMETHING THIS SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH IS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN VALIDATED.
A RECENT JOHN OP AND STUDY ON
THE EFFICACY OF SAME RACE
TEACHERS ESTABLISH THAT.
ONE LOW INCOME BLACK STUDENTS
WHO HAVE AT LEAST ONE BLACK
TEACHER IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND
CONSIDER ATTENDING COLLEGE. TWO
BLACK STUDENTS MATCH WITH BLACK
TEACHERS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO HAVE%
HIGHER TEST SCORES.
THREE SPENDING JUST ONE YEAR
WITH THE TEACHER OF THE SAME
RACE CAN MOVE THE DIAL.
ON ONE OF THE MOST FRUSTRATING
WE PERSISTENT GAPS IN
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
THAT OF LOW INCOME BLACK BOYS
BLACK TEACHERS DON'T ONLY MOVE
THE DIAL THEY MOVE THE DIAL
DRAMATICALLY.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE NUMBER OF BLACK TEACHERS
CALIFORNIA MAYOR IS THE NATION
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIVE TEACHERS TWELVE
THOUSAND ARE BLACK.
BLACK TEACHERS MAKE UP 3% OF THE
TOTAL POPULATION OF TEACHERS
BLACK STUDENTS MAKE UP 5% OF THE
TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION.
NATIONALLY EIGHT OUT OF TEN
TEACHERS ARE WHITE WHILE FEWER
THAN ONE IN TEN ARE BLACK.
THESE STATISTICS STAND IN SHARP
CONTRAST TO STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS
IN US PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OR 47% OF CHILDREN ARE WHITE AND
16% ARE BLACK THE NUMBER OF
BLACK TEACHERS NATIONALLY WOULD
NEED TO MORE THAN DOUBLE FROM
JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND TO ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO THOUSAND IF THEIR
SHARE OF THE EDUCATED WORKFORCE.
WHAT A MATCH THAT OF THE BLACK
STUDENTS RELATIVE TO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL POPULATION?
IT OF ALL THE OBSTACLES TO
BECOMING A TEACHER NATIONALLY
AND IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT POLICY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT RESOURCES ARE
IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
RECENT RESEARCH FROM
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY SUGGESTS
THAT RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AND
BIAS IN SCHOOL DISTRICT HIRING
PRACTICES ARE MAJOR OBSTACLE.
DR DIANE WHITMORE STUDIED A
COURT ORDERED DESEGREGATION CASE
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE HER
QUESTION HOW QUICKLY WAS
DISTRICT POLICY ABLE TO MAKE A
CHANGE IN ULTIMATELY.
HOW DID THAT IMPACT STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT?
FROM NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE DISTRICT
HAD ON HAVE RETIRED A SMALLER
PORTION OF BLACK TEACHERS
NINETEEN POINT 8% THEN HAD OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
TWENTY FOUR POINT 1%.
AFTER THE COURT ORDERED CRITERIA
WENT INTO EFFECT IN TWENTY TEN
THE NUMBER OF BLACK TEACHERS
HIRED SPIKE DRAMATICALLY.
BY TWENTY FOURTEEN NEW HIRES AND
JUSTICE WERE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
LIKELY TO BE BLACK THIRTY TWO
POINT 2% THE NEW TEACHERS ARE
HIRED STATE WHY TWENTY ONE POINT
7%.
THE INFLUX OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
AFRICAN AMERICAN EDUCATORS WAS
ABLE TO SHRINK THE BLACK STUDENT
TO BLACK TEACHER RATIO AND
REDUCE THE REPRESENTATION CAP BY
FOUR PERCENTAGE POINTS.
AND THE BLACK WHITE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP DISPARITY IN TEST SCORES
NARAL BY 5% [inaudible]
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOCUS ON PRACTICES BY EXEMPLARY
DISTRICTS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. FOR
DISTRICTS EXPAND YOUR
RECRUITMENT POOL DEVELOP
SYSTEMIC CONSISTENT WAYS OF
RECRUITING INTERVIEWING HIRING
AND RETAINING TEACHERS.
DISTRICTS AND POLICY MAKERS.
REFORM HIRING PROTOCOL AND
PRACTICES FOCUS ON DIVERSITY
FUND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOSTER A SYSTEMIC CULTURE OF
VALUING TEACHERS OF COLOR.
EXPAND AB TWO FOUR ONE COM
LONGER DOUBLE IMPLICIT BIAS
TRYING TO APPLY TO DISTRICTS
TEACHER EDUCATION AND
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
THERE IS IN FACT A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
WKA KELLOGG FOUNDATION AND CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE IT'S
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A THREE YEAR
GRANT.
IT'S CALLED THE MINORITY MALE
TEACHERS PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT IS FOCUSED ON
INTENTIONALLY RECRUITING
RETAINING AND SUPPORTING BLACK
AND BROWN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
SUPPORT SEE IF YOU USE EFFORTS.
AND REPLICATE ALL TO ALL TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES.
NONTRADITIONAL TEACHER EDUCATION
AND PREPARATION PROGRAMS LIKE
FORTUNE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
FORMALLY PROJECT PIPELINE.
INTEREST IN ITS PRE SERVICE AND
DISTRICT INTERN CURRICULUM.
FOCUSED ON PREPARING TEACHERS TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AS A TWO
POINT TWO PLUS TWO PLUS THREE
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS WHO WANT TO
BECOME LAWYERS ABOUT GEORGE LAW
SCHOOL.
THIS TYPE OF PIPELINE PROGRAM
MUST BE CREATED FOR TEACHER
EDUCATION.
SEE IF YOU SACRAMENTO EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND PROGRAMMING LED BY
DR JULIAN HELICOPTER TO HOLD THE
CHAVEZ AND DOCTOR DEAN CALLIN.
WILL BE A PRIME CANDIDATE FOR
THE ADOPTION OF THE TWO PLUS TWO
PLUS TWO PROGRAM TO CREATE A
GUARANTEE TRANSFER PROGRAM FOR
SPYING TEACHERS.
ALL OF THE SPEAKERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ARE RUNNING
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT WILL
CREATE THE TEACHERS THAT WILL
HELP IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE TO DESERVE YOUR
INVESTIGATION SUPPORT AND
REPLICATION.
THANK YOU.
SO GIVE QUESTION SCREWED I
APOLOGIZE REPEAT YOUR NAME FOR
ME ANGELA WILLIAMS THANK YOU.
FORGET WHICH WAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SO.
SOME OF THE DISORDER WE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT WE KNOW
THAT.
STUDENTS WHO HAVE A TEACHER WHO
LOOKS LIKE THEM IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT I THINK BECAUSE OF LONG
STANDING BIASES POLICIES WE'VE.
THE SYSTEM.
IS WERE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
GETTING SORT OF TEACHERS IN THE
SCHOOLS THEY NEED TO BE AND AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
IN THE LOWER ECONOMIC.
END OF THE SCALE TEND TO BE THE
ONES THAT HAVE HIGHER
POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS OF COLOR
SO WE NEED TO PUT TEACHERS THERE.
WE KNOW THAT.
AND YET WE AND WE PUT TEACHERS
IN THOSE CLASSROOMS.
THAT -- TEND TO BE LESS
EXPERIENCE THAN THE MENTOR
TEACHERS ME THIS THIS IS SORT OF
THE THING THAT WE HAVE
PERPETUATED.
SO IF WE'RE GONNA PUT.
NEWER TEACHERS AND WE RECRUIT
THESE TEACHERS AND WE DO A
REALLY GOOD JOB BY DEFINITION
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE YOUNG
TEACHERS NEWER TEACHERS.
AND THEY CAN BENEFIT THE
STUDENTS BUT WHO'S NOW
BENEFITING THOSE TEACHERS.
AND SO FOR FOR A TEACHER.
I'M ASSUMING THE TEACHER IS IS
ALSO SO IN AT A BLACK TEACHER
HAVING A BLACK TEACHER MENTOR
WOULD BE IDEAL.
HOW DO YOUNG TEACHERS RESPOND
THOUGH BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT MANY?
BLACK MENTOR TEACHERS WERE GONNA
HAVE WHITE MENTOR TEACHERS OR
OTHERS HOW WELL DO THOSE YOUNG
TEACHERS RESPOND TO MENTORS WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY LOOK LIKE.
THEY DO.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO THAT
TO GET OVER THIS HURDLE.
SO WE HAVE SOME SOME SYSTEM OF
THINGS WE HAVE TO OVERCOME.
AND I AM VERY DISTURBED BY.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE BISON RECRUITING IN THE VICE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BRING.
TEACHERS INTO THIS PIPELINE.
BUT IT WE DON'T BY DEFINITION
HAVE THE THAT THE RIGHT SUPPORTS
FOR THOSE TEACHERS.
WE'RE GONNA LIMP ALONG HOW DO WE
DO THAT HOW DO WE CREATE THE
SYSTEM THAT THAT ENDS UP LOOKING
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO NEED.
TO THAT WE CAN THEN BRING INTO
THAT PIPELINE.
THE RATE.
THE RIGHT TEACHERS SO THAT THEY
CAN THEN BECOME THOSE TEACHER
MENTORS THAT OTHERS MAY BE
LOOKING MORE BROADLY SO NOT JUST
TEACHERS THAT LOOKS SO FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A FARLEY STUDY
THAT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
STUDENTS THAT A TEACHER I
DIVERSE TEACHER NOT EVEN
NECESSARILY THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
AFRICAN AMERICAN BUT STILL
BENEFIT ME AS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN MAYBE MORE
BROADLY SO NOT EXACTL A MATCH
AND THEN ALSO LOOKING AT THE
EMPLOYMENT HOLD AFFINITY HOLE.
SO I AM THAT TWENTY YEAR VETERAN
STAFF MEMBER COULD ALSO BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO A NEW TEACHER DO
YOU SEE WHAT I MEAN LOOK AT THE
WHOLE.
AND SO IF I'M IN LIKE THAT COULD
IN STAFF AND THERE'S SOMEONE IN
THAT GROUP THAT CAN SUPPORT ME I
SUPPORT DEANS AND ADMINISTRATORS
ALL THE TIME AND I'M NOT A D.
NORMAN STRAIGHTER R FACULTY BUT
I SUPPORT THEM ALL THE TIME.
AND SO WITH THAT CAN HAPPEN I
THINK THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO THAT'S A ONE PIECE THAT
WE CAN JUST BROADEN THAT.
AND SO THAT YOU'RE GETTINGWHAT
YOU NEED FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE VERSUS ONE
MENTOR KIND OF RENT CONTROL.
I THINK THE ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
THERE'S SOMETHING SPECIAL ABOUT
BLACK TEACHERS.
NOT MORE SPECIAL NOT LESS
SPECIAL TO SOMETHING SPECIAL
ABOUT BLACK TEACHERS
PARTICULARLY BLACK MALE TEACHERS.
I THINK IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
THE STEREOTYPES IN SOCIETY SO.
I'M AN UNUSUAL SUSPECT SOMEONE
ACTUAL OPEN CLASS WHETHER
THEY'RE BLACK STUDENTS OR OTHER
STUDENTS.
I GET A LOOK.
WHO'S THIS GUY RIGHT.
THAT LOOK ACTUALLY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT NOW THE DATA AND THE
REPORTS IN THE RESEARCH AND JOHN
OFTEN SIMPLY.
LOOKS AT THE A PRETTY INTENSIVE
STUDY.
OF HOW DO WE GET OVER THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND SO THE DATA IS THE DATA
RIGHT BLACK TEACHERS WITH BLACK
STUDENTS.
THE QUITE LITERALLY RIGHT AND I
CAN BEGIN THE DISTURBING A COPY
TO REPORT TO LOOK AT THE
FINDINGS AND INVESTIGATE TO
SNIFF AGAINST THE POPULATION
SIZE BECAUSE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
LOOK AT I THINK.
THAT -- ELEVATING THE TEACHING
PROFESSION -- IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO ATTRACT EVERYONE TO
THE TEACHING PROFESSION -- OF
THIS HAS A LOT TO DO WITH -- ONE
SUGGESTION THAT I MADE ABOUT
STARTING STARTING TEACHERS OFF
AT A HIGHER SALARY STEP.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT I THINK
THAT -- ANY GOOD TEACHER A
PARTICULARLY GOOD TEACHER
MENTORS ARE A A DEEP VALUE TO
ANY TEACHER.
I THINK ONE FIX AS IT RELATES TO
TRYING TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
BLACK TEACHERS TO BLACK TEACHER
MENTORS IS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE.
THE BLACK FACULTY AND STAFF
ASSOCIATION -- THE BEAUTY OF ALL
THESE SOLUTIONS IS THAT IT TAKES
A VILLAGE AND THEREFORE YOU NEED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS NGOS
SOCIAL SERVICES SO I COULD
IMAGINE A CASE WHERE.
THE DISTRICT HAS HIRING POLICY
RIGHT AND INTENTIONALLY GOES
AFTER AFRICAN AMERICAN TEACHERS
AND THE BLACK FACULTY AND STAFF
ASSOCIATION WHICH SHOULD BE
REPLICATED TO ALL A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
SEVENTY TWO DISTRICTS WITHIN BE
THERE TO SUPPORT THEM TO GIVE
THEM THE INTENSIVE.
KIND OF PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
THAT MAKES THEM EXPERT TEACHERS
AND IT MIGHT I ADD TO THE EQUITY
MINDEDNESS IS WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT SO YOU DON'T SO THAT
EVEN A MENTOR TEACHER WHO ISN'T
OF THE SAME RACE BUT IT EQUITY
MIND IT.
REALLY IMPACTS AND SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHEN A RECRUITMENT
PRACTICES DIVERSE PEOPLE
APPLICANTS AT PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO INCLUSION SOCIAL
JUSTICE EQUITY MINDEDNESS TO
THOSE.
IN BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SMALL POPULATIONS WE WE NEED TO
BROADEN THE NETWORK AS WELL SO
THAT THOSE MENTORS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ON THE SAME CAMPUS
THAT WOULD BE IDEA.
BUT WE WE HAVE.
A SYSTEM STRUCTURE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO OVER COME OVER TIME AND
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE TO BE.
AWARE OF THAT BUT ALSO SINCE WE
LOCK UP UPWARDS OF 30% OF YOUNG
BLACK MEN [inaudible]
WHAT WE'RE?
MAKING THAT POOL SMALLER AND
SMALLER WHEN THAT BECOMES THEN A
VERY HIGH VALUE COMMODITY. TO
BRING IN AND THEN STRATEGICALLY
GET INTO OUR SYSTEM. TO BE ABLE
TO TEACH SO THAT'S THE OTHER
PIECE WERE WORKING ON AND I WAS
GLAD YOU MENTIONED ARE.
INTERESTING THAT YOU MENTION.
THE PIPELINE OF TRYING TO GET
FOLKS OF COLOR I I CHAIR THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN ONE OF MY
BIG CONCERNS RIGHT NOW IS
DIVERSITY IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION.
IT IS A VERY WHITE MALE
PROFESSION. TO OVERCOME THAT IT
WILL WELL WE STARTED THAT
INCLUDE LOOKING AT JUDICIAL
RANKS.
BEEN LOOKING AT THE LEGAL
PROFESSION THIS GOES ALL THE WAY
BACK TO KIDS AND HOW WE FEEL
THAT PIPELINES WERE TRY TO FILL
PIPELINES FOR SCHOOLS.
BUT ALSO TRYING TO FILL
PIPELINES IN VARIOUS OTHER
PROFESSIONS THAT ARE NOT
ACTUALLY DIVERSE AND THAT HAS A
BIG IMPACT IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE TEND TO WALK UP.
AND SO MANY YOUNG BLACK MEN OF
COLOR BECAUSE THE LEGAL SYSTEM
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THEY DO YOU
AND DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM SO WE HAVE.
VARIOUS SYSTEMSTHAT DESPERATELY
DESPERATELY NEED CHANGE IF WE
CAN DO THAT I THINK WE CAN START
TO MAKE THE NUMBERS LOOK BETTER.
BUT OVER COMING BACK.
IS IS ALTERNATELY A BIG
CHALLENGES MENTION IN BRIEF OF
THAT WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA.
YES THE KEY TO UNDERSTAND AND I
KNOW LEGISLATORS HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT REPEALS OF PROP.
THIRTEEN AND LOOKING AT
SERIOUSLY LOOKING AT PROP TWO OH
NINE I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
TO INVESTIGATE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA AGAIN USED TO BE A
PARTICULAR KIND OF LEADER.
WHEN IT CAME TO DIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
STATES WHERE ACTUALLY
REPRESENTATION MATTERED MOST IN
ALL PROFESSIONS AND THEY WERE
PIPELINE?
SO I THINK TWO NINE IS WHAT IT
IS BUT I DO THINK THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING MORE INTENTIONAL AS A
STATE TO REALLY FOCUS ON HIGH
VALUE INDIVIDUALS IF WE KNOW THE
BLACK MALE TEACHERS.
ACCORDING TO JOHN HOPKINS STUDY
INCREASES NOT ALL OF THE TEST
SCORES BUT THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
STUDENTS WILL ACTUALLY GRADUATE
AND WE NEED TO VALUE THOSE MEN
THAT ARE LOCKED UP IN PRISON AS
TEACHERS.
WE CAN CHANGE OUR FRAME.
THAT THESE ARE FUTURE TEACHERS
AND THEN AGAIN WORK WITH C. R.
C. AND C. R. C. -- TO FOCUS ON
EDUCATION PROGRAMS RIGHT IN
PARTICULAR IN PRISON WHEN THEY
CAN'T GET THE KIND OF PRE
SERVICE DISTRICT IN TURN SERVICE
I KNOW.
IT MAY SEEM LIKE A PHENOMENAL TO
SAY HEY A FORMER FELON IS NOW IN
THE DISTRICT INTERN PROGRAM BUT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED.
IT ABSOLUTELY IS AND AND THIS IS
YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THIS AUDIENCE
AND THAT THE MAKE UP OF THE
RACIAL MAKEUP OF IT IS IS.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN A LOT OF
THE OTHER COMMITTEE HEARING SOME
THINGS IT AND WE HAVE TALKED
OURSELVES OUT OF TALKING ABOUT.
REYES WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
POLICY PROP TWO NINE AND OTHERS
I THINK OR THAT WOULD WHEN WE
STOP TALKING ABOUT RACE THE
RACES SWEAT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
AND WE HAVE TALKED HERSELF INTO
THAT THAT WE HAVE SOLVED THAT
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE IT IN USE GO
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT VERY APPARENTLY AND YET
WE HAVE TO CHANGE OUR ADDED TO
QUITE A BIT ABOUT.
WHO WERE GOING TO ACCEPT WE HAD
DEBATE AROUND JURORS WE HAD
DEBATE AROUND HIM AND AND WHO'S
ALLOWED TO SERVE AS A JUROR
WHO'S ALLOWED TO VOTE?
AND WHY WE ARE EXCLUDING VERY
LARGE PARTS OF SIGNIFICANT
PIECES OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS WE CREATE THOSE POLICIES AND
THAT'S ALL A PIECE OF THAT WHO'S
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE TO YOU AND
TO THE PROGRAMS THAT THAT YOUR
TRYING TO PROMOTE WHAT
HISTORICALLY PEOPLE WHO APPLY
FOR POSITIONS COULD AND IF THEY
HAD FELONY CONVICTIONS RIGHT SO
THAT.
THAT WAS THE BERRY SO YOU DON'T
HAVE YOU DON'T HAVE THESE PEOPLE
IN THE PIPELINE AND TEACHING
CURRENTLY BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
EVEN HAVE ACCESS WHEN YOU WALK
UP 30% OF THAT POTENTIAL POOL
WOULD WE EXPECT.
ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
THANK YOU OKAY.
TURNED BACK TOWARD CHAIR THANK
GOD MY GAVEL BACK HOW.
VIKINGS IS DOWN PAN AYE.
FEEL COMPEL I APPRECIATE
CONNECTING THE CONCEPT OF
TEACHING AND MENTORING.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION OF BRING PEOPLE
INTO TEACHING BUT I THINK THAT
GET YOU INTO THE REALM OF THIS
MYSTERY OF THE HUMAN CHEMISTRY.
AND I THINK -- FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS HEARING I'LL JUST POINT OUT.
THAT THERE IS A ME.
AND MENTOR IN.
AND I THINK A CHILD.
NEEDS TO SEE PEOPLE THAT THEY
IDENTIFY WITH IN SCHOOL.
AND WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OF THIS.
LOTS OF KIDS COULD GO TO SCHOOL
SEE BILL THEY WOULD IDENTIFY BUT
FOR THIS POPULATION.
NOT SELL.
IT'S IT'S AN INSTANT THING MY
BEST MAN.
WHEN CITY AND I GOT MARRIED SO
LONG AGO -- THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
FRIEND OF MINE GARY WILLIAMS
WENT ON TO TEACH HIS WHOLE
CAREER IN PACIFIC GROVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
WHICH IS NOT THE MOST URBAN
CHALLENGED DISTRICT.
BUT STILL WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN
GARY WAS A VERY SPECIAL PERSON
HIS SCHOOL DISTRICT. FOR THE
KIDS GROWING UP IN PACIFIC GROVE.
ARE YEAH I THINK THIS IDEA.
MENTOR AND VERY POWERFUL CONCEPT
ALLY WITH TEACHING.
BUT YOU DO NEED TO FIND.
THE ME AND MENTORING KIDS NEED
TO SEE SOMEONE SO THAT
STATISTICS ABOUT HAVING JUST A
SINGLE.
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE TEACHER
WHEN YOU'RE IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
IS LIKE WOW.
YEAH MEDIAN MENTOR WHILE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING THAT
TODAY.
Q. THANK YOU AND I'M IN MY MY
ISSUES A LITTLE MORE PERSONAL --
MY SON WAS SUPPOSED TO BE HERE
TODAY ON HE'S A TEACHER AT
CHARLES TRUE SCIENCE MAGNET AND
WHAT -- IS THE ONE I SAID
GRADUATE DEGREE IN BIOLOGY AND
MATH -- WHEN HE GRADUATED -- I
TALKED TO THEN SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS DACEY AND TOLD ABOUT MY
SON.
HE SAID WE NEED TO GET HIM.
INTO THE SYSTEM THE TJ MAX IS
TEACHING AP MAP THEY JUST TOTAL
WILL BE TEACHING AP MATH AND AP
BIOLOGY AT CHARLES DREW.
AND SO THERE'S A PRE TRAINING
YOU NEED TO DO AND THAT'S WHY
COULD MAKE IT THIS WEEK -- I
KNOW.
WITH THAT SKILL SET.
IF HE HAD IN FOOTBALL BASKETBALL
IT WAS IN A LIMO TO GO PICK THEM
UP AT THE AIRPORT IT WILL BE A
IN AT AN ABA DRAFT. FOR HIM TO
BE AN DRAFT AND I'M PRETTY SURE
WILL BE PICKED UP IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
IN BE MAKING A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY.
IT TOOK HIM CLOSE TO THREE TO
FIVE YEARS TO GET HIRED.
I'M TOM BOUT THE BUREAUCRACY.
OKAY -- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE.
WHO CAN TEACH AP BIOLOGY?
AND HE CAN'T GET A JOB
[inaudible]
WITH.
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM RIGHT
[inaudible]
NOW.
YES IT SOUNDS LIKE I'M SAYING
MAKING ALLOWANCES FOR MY SON AND
AND I WILL SAY THAT BECAUSE I
THINK HE WOULD BE AN EXTREME
ASSET.
TO LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
EVENTUALLY GOT IN BUT IT SHOULD
NOT TAKE JERRY AND A LOT OF YEAR
ALL PUSH THAT HARDER WANT TO AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM SO THEY DON'T
HAVE PEOPLE WHO.
ARE SERVING A WHO NEED TO BE
THERE RIGHT AND I NEED HIM OFF
MY PAYROLL SHE THE NEWS THAT.
SO I I PAINFULLY KNOW WHAT
THAT'S LIKE -- MISSED YOUR THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS PICKED HIM UP
ALMOST A DAY RIGHT [inaudible]
AND NOTHING WRONG WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT WE NEED A P.
TEACHERS THERE.
TOO BUT WE REALLY NEED A P.
TEACHERS AND WALKS THROUGH
REALLY NEED MALE ROLE MODEL HUMM
IN M. YOU TELL ME WHAT PERCENT
OR SOMEONE SAY LIKE 1% OF THE
TEACHERS AFTER AMERICAN MALE.
HOW MANY AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE
AP BIOLOGY TEACHERS ARE IN THE
WHOLE STATE?
YEAH YES YEAH BECAUSE HE'S HAD
SOME WOULD SET THE COUNTRY --
AGAIN I YOU WERE PLAYING SPORTS
WE WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION THIS IS.
I I DON'T KNOW IF THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT.
THAT KEPT HIM OUT.
SO HOW DO YOU YEAH HOW YOU WORK
WITH THAT.
MEASURE JUST WANT TO MENTION
BRIEFLY THAT THERE IS A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AND SEE
ISSUED NORTHRIDGE WITH THE
DEPUTY CAL UP TO BE K. KELLOGG
FOUNDATION.
IS A MINORITY TEACHER PROJECT I
THINK THAT'S EXEMPLARY I WON
BECAUSE IT'S IN THE CSU SYSTEM
IN THE CSU DOES SO MUCH TO
EDUCATE ONE IN EIGHT EDUCATORS
IN TEACHING CALIFORNIA.
HAVE COME FROM THE C. ISSUE AND
THEY ARE NOW INTENTIONALLY
WORKING WITH ROUGHLY ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THREE YEAR --
PROGRAM AND NOT ENOUGH MONEY BUT
THEY'RE DOING IT ANYWAY AND
THEY'VE GOT TO GET IN THE DEBATE
QUE KELLOGG FOUNDATION IS IN
MICHIGAN.
THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
I THINK ARE BAKED INTO THE PRE
SERVICE AND DISTRICT IN TURN
PROCESS BECAUSE STUDENTS HAVE TO
AFTER THEY GO TO THE PRE SERVICE
AND IS AGAIN TERM PROCESS.
THEY DO HAVE TO PASS PARTICULAR
TESTS RIGHT THEY DO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING IN BETWEEN.
AND SO HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH EXPERTS LIKE THE CSU
EDUCATION EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS.
AROUND FIGURING OUT HOW -- THE
THE FREE SERVICE AND DISTRICT IN
TURN SERVICE CAN TURN INTO -- AN
ACTUAL FULL TIME JOB NOW WHEN
THEY BECOME DISTRICT INTERNS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PLACED.
IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT -- WILL
THEY STAY THAT'S BASED UPON WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IN TERMS OF
COMPLETING THE REQUIREMENTS IN
ORDER TO BE A FULLY CERTIFIED
TEACHER.
BUT I THINK THAT CONVERSATION IN
YOUR THAT YOUR CONCERNS ARE NOT
JUST A ONE OFF.
IT'S A SYSTEM WIDE ISSUE AND I
THINK THE BEST WAY TO HANDLE IT
IS TO GET A SYSTEM WIDE
ORGANIZATION LIKE SEE ISSUE
ENGAGED.
WITH THE EXPERTS THAT ARE THERE
TO REALLY FOCUS ON HOW DO WE
CREATE THAT KIND OF VALUE ADDED
KNOWING THAT.
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE TEACHER
TEACHING MATH CALCULUS SCIENCE
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO FOR
SERIOUS ABOUT STEM AND STEAM.
AND I THINK SEE ISSUE WITH WOULD
BE THE PERFECT PARTNER TO THINK
THROUGH HOW DO WE VALUE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN.
THAT ARE TEACHERS THAT WANT TO
COME INTO THE TEACHING
PROFESSION NOT JUST LOOTED COULD
NOT TO WORK THAT HARD.
ONE BOB THIS IS AFTER YOU PASS
TO SEE BEST.
IT TOOK HIM TWO YEARS TO GET
INTO THAT PROGRAM YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEN IT TOOK.
SOME TIME BEFORE IT BECAME A
PERMANENT TEACHER YES.
HE WENT TO MORE HOUSE IN BIOLOGY
IS THE HARDEST DEGREE YOU CAN
GET.
IN ANY HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGE AND MORE HOUSES BIOLOGY
DEGREE IS ONE OF THE HARDEST TO
GET IN ANY HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGE.
GO TO A STARK BLACK COLLEGES AND
RECRUIT.
WHY WITH WHAT?
DESPITE WHAT WHAT WHAT SOMEBODY
FROM I WOULD TASTE SOMEBODY FROM
ARKANSAS STATE WE LOVE THE COME
OUT HERE.
AND TEACH -- AND AND OTHER
PLACES AND SO -- WE WE MAKE WE
MAKE IT HARDER ON OURSELVES
SOMETIMES DANCE IS JUST RIGHT
THERE WE JUST DON'T DO IT.
AND SO -- BEEN IN AND HAVING
INTERNSHIPS OR WHERE YOU COULD
GOTO A MORE HOUSE FROM CAL
STATE.
AND THEN COME BACK HERE AND
FINISH YOUR YOUR TEACHING COULD
BE SOMETHING THAT COULD THAT
COULD BE BENEFICIAL BUT WE JUST
NEEDED TO DO A BETTER SANDRA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THEN ARE FOR IT.
OUR LAST PANEL [inaudible]
OF RETAINING.
TEACHER RETENTION.
RETAINING TEACHERS TO IN THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AB
DOUBLE WALK INS.
AND ANTHONY.
ERIN DILLON ERA WHEN Y. AIRLINE
THEY PUT A ã ON HERE OKAY
THAT'S RIGHT CITY.
SO -- I'M SITTING BACK THERE THE
AMEN CORNER.
SO LET'S THAT HAS BEEN SAID IS
IN MY ACTUAL MY NOTES.
AND I TALK A LOT SO I WROTE MINE
DOWN.
SO THAT I COULD GET THROUGH IN
MY FIVE MINUTES SO -- I'VE COME
TO THE FRIGHTENING CONCLUSION
THAT I AM THE DECISIVE ELEMENT
IN THE CLASSROOM.
IT'S MY PERSONAL APPROACH THAT
CREATES THE CLIMATE.
IT'S MY DAILY MOOD THAT MAKES
THE WEATHER.
AS A TEACHER I POSSESS A
TREMENDOUS POWER TO MAKE A
CHILD'S LIFE MISERABLE OR IF
CHOI WITH.
I CAN BE A TOOL OF TORTURE ONE
INSTRUMENT OF INSPIRATION.
I CAN HUMILIATE OR HE'LL.
IT ALL SITUATION IT IS MY
RESPONSE.
WILL BE ESCALATED.
OR DE ESCALATED.
AND A CHILD HUMANIZED.
OR DE HUMANIZED AND THAT'S FROM
I'M GET OUT.
I BEGIN CHAPTER.
TWO OF MY BOOK.
THOUGHT HELD HOSTAGE A BLACK
TEACHES JOURNEY OF UNLOCKING
YOUR LINES WITH THIS POWERFUL
QUOTE.
THE CHAPTER IS ENTITLED THEY
WERE THE ONES TEACHERS WHO
INFLUENCED MY JOURNEY.
AND I PROFILE SEVEN TEACHERS WHO
AYE CHANNEL IN MY OWN TEACHING.
ALL OF MY TEACHERS WERE WHITE.
K. THROUGH.
TWELVE AND I THRIVED UNDER THEIR
TUTELAGE.
BUT MY DARK SKIN BROTHER.
JUST ONE YEAR BEHIND ME.
WAS TRAUMATIZED BY MOST OF THEM.
AND PLACED ON THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE IN KINDERGARTEN.
BECAUSE HE WAS MISUNDERSTOOD.
AND LABELED OPPOSITIONAL.
LET ME START AT THE ONSET OF MY
JOURNEY.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM THE
STANFORD TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN I'M ALL.
WITH A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
EDUCATION.
AND LIFETIME TEACHING
CREDENTIALS IN ENGLISH FRENCH
AND PSYCHOLOGY.
I STARTED TEACHING IN THE
LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SILICON VALLEY.
THE EAST SIDE UNION.
AT THAT TIME THE AVERAGE GPA FOR
BLACK STUDENTS WAS ONE POINT.
FIVE WHEN I RETIRED SEVEN YEARS
EARLY FROM THAT DISTRICT EIGHT
YEARS AGO.
THE AVERAGE GPA FOR BLACK
STUDENTS WITH ONE POINT.
NINE THAT IS CRIMINAL.
IN ORDER TO COMBAT THIS TRAVESTY.
I WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALLIANCE A
BLACK EDUCATORS THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
AND ONE OF OUR SIGNATURE EVENTS
WAS AN ANNUAL STUDENT AWARDS
CEREMONY HONORING HUNDREDS OF
BLACK STUDENTS TRANSITIONING
FROM FIFTH SIXTH.
EIGHTH AND TWELFTH GRADES WE
CELEBRATED OUR THIRTIETH YEAR
LAST MONTH.
I WAS STILL JUST A BANDAID.
SO AFTER SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALLIANCE
A BLACK EDUCATORS FROM NINETY
FOUR TO THE OTHER ONE I FOUND AT
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN EDUCATORS NOW
CALLED A BLACK EDUCATION NETWORK.
IF I HAD WITNESSED FIRST HAND
THE POWER OF THE TEACHER TO
HUMAN LIFE OR DE HUMANIZE.
I COLD CALLED I COLD CALLED DR
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND.
WHO HAD ARRIVED TO STANFORD
UNIVERSITY IF YOU USE A FEW
YEARS EARLIER AND ASKED HER IF
SHE WOULD HELP ME TO CREATE A
SUMMER INSTITUTE FOCUS ON
EQUIPPING TEACHERS TO
SUCCESSFULLY REACH?
STUDENTS OF AFRICAN ANCESTRY.
LINDA NEVER HESITATED AND EVEN
UNDER WROTE THE INSTITUTES FOR
THE FIRST THREE YEARS AS PART OF
A LARGE GRANT THAT SHE HAD FOR
HER SCHOOL WE DESIGN NETWORK.
FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS WE
FEATURE TO ROCK STARS IN
EDUCATION AT OUR INSTITUTE AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE FLOCK TO THEM.
MANY OF THE FEATURES SCHOLARS
HAVE WRITTEN BOOKS THAT ARE USED
IN SCHOOLS OF EDUCATION ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THEY INCLUDED
DOCTORS BOB MOSES TWICE.
BEVERLY DANIEL TATUM GLORIA
LADSON BILLINGS PAGE ON THE GEAR.
WAIT NOBLES LISA DELPY SURE
ROCKY ALI CAROL LEE AND JUDY THE
GAY.
ALTHOUGH THE INCIDENTS WERE
HIGHLY ACCLAIMED MANY ATTENDEES
SHARE WITH ME THAT THEY WERE NOT
GETTING TRACTION IN THE FIELD.
WHAT THE GREAT PRACTICES THAT
THEY WERE LEARNING DUE TO
SYSTEMIC RACISM?
SO WE TOOK A HIATUS FOR FOUR
YEARS AND WORKED ON STATEWIDE
POLICY.
DURING THIS TIME THE LOCAL UNTIL
FUNDING FORMULA WITH.
AND THAT WAS PRECISELY THE
POLICY MANDATE THAT WE NEEDED.
FOUR YEARS AGO WE RESUMED THE
HOSTING THE INSTITUTES IN A
FEATURED.
DOCTORS ARE NEED THE BALL STEVEN
HANCOCK BEVERLY DATA TATUM A
SECOND TIME AND BRIAN BROWN MORE
ROCK STARS.
OUR INSTITUTE FOCUS ON PREPARING
TEACHERS WITH ACTIVELY DELIVER
HERITAGE KNOWLEDGE IN THE
CURRICULUM.
THAT'S ENHANCING STUDENT
LEARNING AND ENGAGEMENT AND
REDUCING HARSH DISCIPLINE AND
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION
DISPARITIES THAT FUEL THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE.
WE HAVE RECEIVED REPORT AFTER
REPORT AFTER REPORT ABOUT IMPACT
FOR THE INSTITUTES HAVE BEEN ON
HELPING TEACHER.
IMPROVE TEACHER EFFECTIVENESS SO
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE SELECT
COMMITTEE CONSIDER WAYS THE
SCALE WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO HELP
IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO I
STARTED IF THE PROGRAM IN THE
HEART OF SILICON VALLEY.
UNAPOLOGETICALLY FOCUSED ON
BLACK STUDENTS. 1100% OF OUR
STUDENTS.
IN ROLE IN COLLEGE. 90% GRADUATE
IN FOUR YEARS WOULD BE A OR B.
F. DEGREES. 60% EARNED DEGREES
IN STEM WHICH IS EIGHT TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR BLACK
STUDENTS.
WITH THE RACE THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE CAN'T DO THE
THING.
AS FAR AS TEACHER RECRUITMENT IS
CONCERNED WE RECOMMEND THAT THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE CONSIDER
HELPING TO CREATE FUTURE
TEACHERS FOR BLACK AMERICA
CHAPTERS.
ON HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES AROUND
THE STATE.
THEY WILL BE WILL BE MODELED
AFTER FUTURE TEACHERS OF AMERICA.
BUT THEY WILL SPECIFICALLY FOCUS
ON BLACK STUDENTS TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO BECOME TEACHERS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND CULTIVATING
ALLIANCES WITH HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
H. B. C. USE TO ENCOURAGE THEIR
EDUCATION MAJORS TO TEACH IN
CALIFORNIA. TO HELP THEM WITH
THE COST OF LIVING IN THE STATE
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE SHOULD
OFFER HOUSING SUPPORT.
AS LONG AS THE POTENTIAL TEACHER
COMMITS TO WORKING AT LEAST FIVE
YEARS.
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL WHERE AT
LEAST 10% OF THE POPULATION IS
BLACK. EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN GROUND BREAKING STUDY
CO AUTHORED BY JOHN HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY ECONOMIST FOUND THAT
HAVING JUST ONE BLACK TEACHER IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED A LOW INCOME BLACK
STUDENTS THE LIKELIHOOD.
OF GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
IN CONSIDERING COLLEGE. FOR A
VERY LOW INCOME BOYS THE RISK OF
DROPPING OUT WAS REDUCED BY 939%.
FINALLY I RECOMMEND THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE EMBRACE THE
POWERFUL WORK OF THE DIGNITY THE
SCHOOLS CAMPAIGN.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO DISMANTLE
FORTY TWO COUNCIL I HELP GUIDE
ITS WORK.
WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
IF EVERY SCHOOL IN THIS COUNTRY
MERELY ADOPTED DS SEES MODEL
COLD AND IMPLEMENTED IT WELL.
WE WOULD IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE IN A FEW YEARS.
IN TENTH GRADE MY BROTHER CAUGHT
WITH CALL THE IN WIRED.
BY A WHITE TEACHER.
ANY THROUGH A DESK IN HER.
IT WAS EXPELLED FROM THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
OF MY MOTHER'S TEN CHILDREN HE
WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO DROPPED OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL STARTED SELLING
DRUGS AND WITH IN AND OUT OF
JAIL.
AT TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD HE WAS
MURDERED.
BY AN UNKNOWN ASSAILANT.
HECK EVEN ONE TEACHER RECOGNIZE
THE GENIUS OF MY GIVE TO BROTHER.
AND RESCUE HIM FROM THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE.
PERHAPS HE WOULD BE ALIVE AND
THRIVING TODAY.
BECAUSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO
CONFRONT THE END OF THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE HEAD ON WITH
HIS HEARING.
A RECOMMENDATION THAT WILL COME
OUT OF IT I'M GOING TO LAND HILL.
THIS COPY OF MY BOOK.
UNTIL LIKE IN ORDER HILL.
ONE BETWEEN ITS PAGES.
YOU WILL COME TO UNDERSTAND THAT
RECRUITING DEVELOPING AND
RETAINING CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
TEACHERS IS A CRITICAL KEY TO
ENDING THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY TEST.
THANK YOU.
NEXT IS YOUR BOOK.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
YES IT DOES.
WHEN I REYES SO I'M OPPOSITE OF
HER I DON'T SPEAK LONG -- ANYWAY
MY NAME IS ANTHONY AIRLINE AND
I'M ACTUALLY A CLASSROOM TEACHER
FOR THE LAST NINETEEN YEARS --
IN SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
WORKING BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT --
SO THEY ARE VERY PROUD OF I'VE.
I WAS THINKING THAT REFLECT THE
EARLIER ABOUT.
IF I'VE EVER HAD A BLACK TEACHER.
IN MY EDUCATIONAL CAREER I DON'T
HAVE A BLACK TEACHER AND TAUGHT
WITH IN TENTH GRADE.
OF FEMALE WHO ACTUALLY INSPIRED
ME TO BE A TEACHER JUST FOR HER
SHOWING UP. TO ALL WHITE SCHOOL
THEY DIDN'T WANT HER TO BE THERE
TEACHING ENGLISH AND THAT WAS
REALLY INSPIRING TO ME HER
COURAGE.
AND THEN I DIDN'T HAVE A BLACK
MALE TEACHER AND SO GRAD SCHOOL.
OF THE FIRST HARPER SAW BLACK NO
TEACHER -- IN MY CAREER I TEACH
KINDERGARTEN FIRST GRADE AND
SECOND GRADE SO WHEN I SHOW UP
THE KIDS ARE EXCITED KIDS
RUNNING DOWN THE HALL CABIN YOUR
CLASSROOM.
I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS BECAUSE
I WAS A BLACK MALE THEY HAD
NEVER SEEN A BLACK MALE TEACHER
BEFORE [inaudible]
SO.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME TO
BE IN THE BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT
BEING A ROLE MODEL FOR THOSE
STUDENTS AND SHOWING THEM THAT
THERE IS.
PURPOSE AND VALUE IN BEING AS IN
EDUCATION AND THAT THEY COULD BE
TEACHER THAT THEY WANT TO BE --
YOU ASKED EARLIER ABOUT TO ASK
IF YOU GAVE ME A BLANK CHECK AND
I COULD.
ASK YOU FOR ANYTHING
[inaudible]
I I ONE OF THE THINGS I'M PROUD
OF IS I'M PART OF THE BLACK
TEACHER PROJECT AND WHAT WE DO
IS AFFINITY SPACE.
OF PROGRAM FUNDED BY DOCTOR
MISTER MOSELY -- IN NEW YORK
CITY.
IS SHE HAVE TWO CHAPTERS HERE IN
THE BAY AREA ONE IN SAN
FRANCISCO ONE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
IS SHE BRINGS TOGETHER BLACK
TEACHERS FROM ALL OVER THE BAY
AREA TO DEEPEN OUR SKILLS AND TO
THINK DEEPLY ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE CLASSROOM AND HOW
WE CAN ELEVATE BLACK CHILDREN.
FROM PRE K. TO CAN FOR A PRE K.
TWELVE GRADE.
AND HOW WE CAN.
THE CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENTGAP
BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE
CLASSROOM.
ALSO THE WAY TO HELP RETAIN
BLACK TEACHERS UNTIL THAT
PROJECT I HAD NEVER SEEN MORE
THAN THREE BLACK TEACHERS AT ONE
TIME IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO WHEN TWENTY TEACHERS SO THAT
THEY'RE ALL BLACK IT WAS LIKE
WOW.
WERE FAMILY.
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE
HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING FUNDING.
FOR THOSE TYPES OF PROGRAMS WE
HAVE TO BIG.
RIGHT ALL TYPES OF GRANTS AND WE
MAY GET A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IF SO WE CAN'T PAY TEACHERS FOR
THEIR TIME TO COME AFTER SCHOOL
TO BE A PART OF THESE GROUPS.
SO IF I COULD ASK FOR ANYTHING
IT WOULD BE TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT KEEP.
BLACK TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOMS
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE OTHER THING IS I WOULD ASK
THAT WE COULD.
INCLUDE MORE BLACK MALE TEACHERS
IN THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS IN THE ROOM
WHEN THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT US AND FOR US IN THE
CLASSROOM SO GIVEN US MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE DECISIONS.
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THE OTHER THING WOULD BE.
MENTOR SHIP.
WE ARE WE HAVE THE BEGINNING
TEACHER PROGRAM AND WE HAVE SO
THE OTHER STATE PROGRAMS WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING SPECIFIC. TO
BLACK TEACHERS.
OR TEACHERS OF COLOR BECAUSE WE
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT STRUGGLES AND
WE NEED SOMEONE THAT CAN COME IN
AND HELP US.
NAVIGATE THOSE SYSTEMS
ESPECIALLY FROM A PERSON OF
COLOR AS POINT OF VIEW.
SO THOSE WOULD BE THE THINGS I
WOULD ASK.
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU -- AND
IT MIGHT.
NOT JUST QUICKLY -- JUST MENTION
IS MIKE MY COLLEAGUES REMINDED
ME THAT AND IN PART AS MAY BE
CONNECTING -- TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE WE WE
WE WERE PUTTING MONEY IN THE
BUDGET. FOR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
FOR THINGS OF THIS NATURE.
AND THEN I'LL GO BACK TO MY
DISTRICT AND SOMEONE CARILLO SAY
WILL GO BACK TO OUR DISTRICT AND
ASK FOR THAT IN A ROW WHAT DID
YOU APPLY.
AND WE'LL FIND THE DUE DATE HAS
PASSED.
I MEAN IT DIRT THERE IS MONEY
FOR FOR FOR EXAMPLE MY DISTRICT
FOR CHURCHES.
AND I'VE HAD.
LATINO AND AFTER AMERICAN
CHURCHES FIND OUT AFTER THE DUE
DATE AND THEY COULD HAVE GOTTEN
YOU KNOW FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
BE HUGE.
TO SOME DISTRICTS TO TO START A
PROGRAM AND SO WE PROBABLY NEED
TO ALSO DO A BETTER JOB OF OF
CONNECTING.
YOU WITH WHAT THE RESOURCES
THERE ARE A OUT THERE -- BECAUSE
I I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY A LOT
OF MISSED OPPORTUNITIES GOING ON
THREE ACES PROGRAM.
GOOD. FOR THE THE THINKING AS
CHAIR AND AND TO THAT SAME POINT --
EVEN IN THE DEAD BUT THE
DISTRICTS THAT DO APPLYING GET
FUNDING ARE THE RIGHT
ADMINISTRATORS IN THOSE
DISTRICTS MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISION ABOUT THAT MONEY.
OR THEY JUST PUTTING INTO
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'VE ALWAYS PUT
INTO.
AND AND HOW MUCH ACCOUNTABILITY
IS THERE FOR THAT MONEY BECAUSE
CERTAINLY A LOT OF MONEY COMES
DOWN -- WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MEANS PROGRESS COMING UP AND AND
HAS A REALLY GOING TO THE
STUDENTS THAT NEED IT.
AND AN ON THE SPOT BECAUSE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME BECAUSE YOU
TAUGHT AT MY ALMA MATER OAK OF
HIGH SCHOOL.
ANY SIDE UNION.
RETIRED FROM TEACHING BUT SHE'S --
STILL STILL TAKE PEOPLE TO
SCHOOL.
LED TO A BUT NO BUT I MEAN TO TO
YOUR OPENING POINTS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE I THINK MS
WATKINS I MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE AN
EXAMPLE OF OF YOU.
SAW THE STUDENTS YOU HEARD THE
STUDENTS AND THEY DEFINITELY
FELT LOVED AND I THINK THAT'S A
BIG PART OF IT.
IS TO FEEL APPRECIATED AND AND
WHEN I WOULD COME TO TO THE
SCHOOL AND AND MEET THE STUDENTS --
IT DID YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT
COMPETENCE IS THERE THAT'S WHY
YOU HAVE THE SUCCESS -- BUT
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY OF YOU TO
GO AROUND THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE INSTILL THAT.
IN OTHER TEACHERS OTHER
ADMINISTRATORS FOLKS ARE RUNNING
ON PROSPECTS ARE GOING INTO OUR
SCHOOLS BECAUSE BEING IN SILICON
VALLEY WELL THERE'S A BUNCH OF
MONEY.
THAT COMES IN FROM FOUNDATIONS
AND ALL THESE TECH COMPANIES
TALKING ABOUT STEM FOR GIRLS AND
STEM FOR MINORITIES ALL THAT
MORE THIS MONEY COMING IN OVER
MENTORING AND BUT ARE THEY
REALLY LISTENING ARE THEY REALLY
SEEING THE STUDENTS.
OR IS IT JUST SOMETHING TO CHECK
A BOX SAYING ALL WE CARE ABOUT
STEM WE CARE ABOUT IN A MINORITY
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE I TELL
YOU THIS -- BEING IN SILICON
VALLEY I'VE BEEN HEARING FOR
DECADES FOR THIRTY YEARS ABOUT --
WE NEED MORE WOMEN WE NOR PEOPLE
KALRA. TO APPLY FOR THESE I
DON'T HAVE THE POOL OF
APPLICANTS YOU THAT THIRTY YEARS
TO CREATE A POOL OF APPLICANTS
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE WITH THAT
TIME.
IN OTHER THAN WRITING A CHECK
HERE AND THERE.
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE MAKING
HIRING DECISIONS THERE'S ARE A
LOT HIRING.
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE NOT HIRING WOMEN EVEN THOUGH --
THE DAY OF THE THE THE NUMBERS
SHOW THAT THEY ARE THERE BEYOND
THE NUMBER OF THOSE THAT ARE
APPLYING.
ARE THEY ARE THEY ARE NOT
ABSOLUTELY NOT AND THAT'S WHERE
THE WORK HERE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED --
YOU KNOW AS AS A SUMMER STONE
WAS SAYING EARLIER TALK ABOUT
LAWYERS AND LOCK REPRESENTATION.
AT THE START OF THEIR KIDS.
WE DON'T WAIT TO SOMEONE'S GOING
TO UNDERGRAD SO HE WANT TO BE A
LAWYER.
YOU KNOW USED TO START INSTILLED
WHEN THEY'RE DONE WITH THEIR
YOUNGER THAT CONFIDENCE SAID
THEN THEY CAN DECIDE WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO BUT YOU HAVE TO
CREATE THE CREATE.
THE THE THE THE THE BELIEF AND
AND I REMEMBER.
ACTUALLY GOES BLACK KITCHEN
CABINET MEETING WHERE IT WAS
DISCUSSED THE ONE POINT FIVE GPA
FROM SEVENTY NINE TO THE IT'S
ONE POINT NINE MILLION THIRTY
PLUS YEARS LATER.
AND IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF YOU AND
OTHERS THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE
GROUND AS A LACK OF SUPPORT. FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING --
EVEN WITH THE SUCCESS YOU HAVE
IN THE MICROCOSM OF THE STUDENTS
YOU CAN YOU YOU'VE SHOWN YOU
YOU'VE YOU'VE PROVEN.
THE MODEL.
AND AND SO I THINK IT'S UP TO US
DâN TO SCALE IT.
RIGHT SPEAKING IN -- SO CANNELLA
TERMS WE NEED TO SCALE THE MODEL
BUT BUT AND THAT'S WHY I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOUR HERE --
AND THE OTHER IS THAT IT
PRESENTED WHEN I WAS PRESENTING
I MEAN SENATE COMMITTEE IS.
THE BECAUSE THIS CONVERSATION AS
I WAS SAYING MY OPENING COMMENTS
THAT THE TIMING IS IS -- IS WHAT
IS WELL OVERDUE BUT THE SAME
TIME IT'S IT'S IT'S GOOD TIMING
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT.
IF WITH THIS WITH THIS HEARING
WAS HER TEN YEARS AGO WE WERE WE
WERE STILL LOCKING PEOPLE UP WE
WE WE WEREN'T EVEN.
THE WE WENT IN THERE YET MAYBE
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
WHERE.
BUT NOT AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY
NOT AS A STATE.
I THINK NOW WITH WE HAVE THE
RIGHT GOVERNOR IN PLACE WE HAVE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS -- AND WE
HAVE ACADEMIC LEADERS THAT ARE
THAT ARE READY LIKE RARING TO GO
AND SO I'M VERY I MEAN THIS IS
THE FIRST -- BUT SELECT
COMMITTEEWERE HAVING ON THIS
BUT IT WILL LEAD TO LEGISLATION
THAT WILL LEAD TO BUDGET ASK
BECAUSE THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
THE SLACK COMMITTEES AND I KNOW --
CHAIR JONES SAWYER I'VE BEEN
WHEN HE WAS SHARING -- THIS
LACKEY ASSASSIN WISEMAN COLOR HE
IS AS INTO THIS FOR SHOW THAT IT
ENDS UP WITH RESULTS AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT WITH THE MONEY THAT'S
BEEN COMING INTO THE BUDGET
PROCESS -- BUT IT'S NOT -- YOU
KNOW A LOT OF OTHER BUDGET
REQUESTS ON THE CAN JUST COME
FOR EXAM NINETY YEAH WHEN IT
COMES A BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE
PICKING UP.
OF OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR WHEN
IT COMES TO YOU KNOW THE KIND OF
THE TOP AS WE TALK ABOUT WE AT
THE TIME OF THE RECEIPTS. TO
SHOW THAT IT'S A YOU KNOW AND SO
THIS IS PART AGAIN THE RECEIPTS
TOGETHER SO ON THE ASKS ARE MADE
HEY WE'VE HAD THESE HEARINGS
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE EXPERTS.
THIS IS WHERE THIS MONEY CAN GO
AND THESE ARE THE RESULTS CAN
SHOW AND SO I AM I FEEL VERY
HOPEFUL -- UP WITH TODAY'S
HEARING AND THOSE THAT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT -- BUT
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY -- WITH
WHAT'S GONNA COME NEXT AND SO
I'M I'M GRATEFUL TO BOTH YOU AND
THE OTHERS ARE PRESENTED.
AND I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
PART OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THE NGUYEN SHONDA OF STARTED THE
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR MOVEMENTS
YEARS AGO I WAS A PART OF THAT.
SO I'VE BEEN ON THE GROUND I'VE
BEEN I WAS THERE AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR MOVEMENT BUT I NEVER
SEPARATE BOYS FROM GIRLS.
BECAUSE WHO ARE THE GIRLS GONE
MARY RIGHT [inaudible]
THEY I'M JUST SAYING.
IF THEY IF THEY CHOOSE THE RIGHT
WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO MARRY
THE WRITING YOU TO HOLD ME IN.
THE RIGHT SO -- BUT BUT I DO YOU
KNOW -- YOU KNOW AS A FAMILY
MEMBER -- KALRA SAID WE CAN WE
GO WAY BACK -- YOU KNOW HE'S TO
COME TO A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
GRADUATED FROM IN IN IN THAT
DISTRICT.
AND EVERY YEAR HE WOULD YOU KNOW
HE WOULD CREATE THE CERTIFICATE
I'D ASK YOU CREATE THE
CERTIFICATES FOR THESE BLACK
KIDS WHO ARE YOU DON'T GET HIT
BEING RECOGNIZED BY THEIR
TEACHERS.
AS EITHER IMPROVING OR WHATEVER
WE SEE YOU KIDS WITH THE YOU AND
HE WOULD NEVER HESITATE TO GET
CERTIFICATES AND THEN IF TO THE
SCHEDULE.
HE WOULD COME SO THIS MAN HAS
BEEN IN THE WORK A LONG TIME AND
REYES YOU LIKE DOCTOR MARSHALL
OVER THERE -- IN SO -- YOU KNOW%
I AM I FORTY TWO YEARS OF THE
WORK AS WELL -- BUT YOU GIVE
THAT'S WHAT WITH A MAN
EVERYTHING YOU WITH IT OVER
THERE.
I DON'T LIKE THE MAN AFTER MY
OWN HEART IN THE IN THE BEING
BECAUSE I WORK WITH STANFORD
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION YOU
KNOW I WITH I WAS LIKE JUST.
HAVING A FIT THAT JUST COULDN'T
GET IT YOU KNOW I WAS LIKE OH
LORD YOU COULD SET UP TO THE
EAST SIDE.
HAD A JOB LIKE THAT RIGHT SO I'M
JUST THEY AND I'M GLAD HE'S
EMPLOYED NOW DOING A P. MATH AND
SCIENCE BUT WE DO HAVE A STEM
PROGRAM THAT IS READY FOR
REPLICATION IT IS READY FOR
SCALING IS TWENTY YEARS ALL.
IN OUR RESULTS WE RAISE THE GAP
GREAT DID YOU.
I JUST WANTED TO SHARE SOME
NUMBERS.
SO THE AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
AND SAFETY PROGRAMS OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS ASUS WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
AND HAS LESS THAN. TWENTY YEARS
IN A BEING IN AN OPERATION.
CURRENTLY -- THERE WAS SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET TO KEEP
THESE PROGRAM SUSTAINABLE ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MY
OFFICE WAS.
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN MILLION TO KEEP TO
SCALE SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DID AN INCREDIBLE THING WHICH IS
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR RIGHT
WHICH IS A GOOD THING FOR PEOPLE.
HOWEVER.
THERE WAS A SOMETIMES THIS
HAPPENS IN GOVERNMENT THAT YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL THE RIPPLE
EFFECTS TO THAT.
SO THIS PROGRAM.
WELL PAYING PEOPLE MORE.
DID NOT A JUST FOR THE SALARY
INCREASES WHICH MEANS THAT
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO BE LET GO.
AND SEE WHICH ULTIMATELY MEANT
THAT LESS KIDS WERE GOING TO BE
HELPED.
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR MORE FUNDING
FOR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW CRITICAL THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT THEY PLAY --
AND ENSURING THAT KIDS ARE SAFE
THAT FAMILIES FEEL LIKE THEIR
KIDS ARE SAFE AT SCHOOL.
CHILD CARE IS INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE AND SO THESE PROGRAMS
OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CHILDREN TO SAY AT SCHOOL IN A
SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
CONTINUE.
TO LEARN TO READ AND WRITE AND
MATHEMATICS AND STEM
OPPORTUNITIES SO WE HAVE AN AN
ADDITIONAL -- INCREASE IN THE
BUDGET OF FIFTY MILLION THAT
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS AND THIS IS WHERE YOU ALL
PLAY A ROLE.
IN ENSURING THAT.
IT ACTUALLY GET SIGNED UP BY THE
GOVERNOR.
A VERY SOON AS WELL AS THE
ACOMPANYING BILL TO THAT WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT US MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES.
WE CONTINUE TO PUT MORE MONEY TO
ACTUALLY ACCOUNT -- FOR THOSE
SALARY INCREASES ACROSS THE
STATE AND I THINK THAT'S A
THAT'S A WAY IN WHICH WE WORK
WITH THE BUDGET TO ENSURE THAT
OUR KIDS ARE TAKING CARE OF AS
TO THE B. REALLY IMPORT HE'S.
I'M SORRY THREE RECALLS.
A FIFTH OF THE REALLY IMPORTANT
HE SAID -- WHO'S GETTING THAT
MANY THOUGH RIGHT I'M JUST
SAYING WHO'S GETTING THAT MANY
BECAUSE BOSTON PROGRAM IS NEVER
GOT ANY THAT MANY WE RAISED OUR
OWN MANY -- THROUGH GRANTS AND
AND SO FORTH -- BUT YOU KNOW IF
AND I LOVE THE FACT THAT MANY
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
BUT THE VEIL OF ALL SO HOW DO
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THAT I LOVE THE BLACK TEACHER
PROJECT HOW DID THEY LEARN ABOUT
THIS KIND OF MONEY SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT STRUGGLING HAVING
YOU KNOW BIG SALES IN ORDER.
TO DEVELOP THEIR DOORS AND WE'VE
GOT TO DO A BETTER JOB FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE AND GET IN
INFORMATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND SO THAT MIGHT BE A
PROJECT.
WE NEED TO DO AMONGST OURSELVES
TO GET THAT INFORMATION OUT AND
SO THAT WAS.
THAT'S ONE OF MY TO DO LIST
EXOTIC GET THAT OUT -- WE'RE
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE A PRESS
CONFERENCE LIKE RIGHT NOW AND
THIS IS REALLY GREAT. TO MEAN TO
CUT YOU OFF BUT I I HAVE PEOPLE
THAT PROBABLY NEED TO GET
SOMEWHERE.
BUT ALSO.
WHAT ARE A LOT OF PUBLIC COMMENT?
COMING TO THE MIKE.
I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS GO I WANT.
GOING TWICE THREE TIMES -- SO
I'M GOING TO CLOSE THIS NOW.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION -- FOR ANYONE
THAT'S LISTENING -- I'LL JUST
SAY THIS ROSS YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A MORE ROSE BUS ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT LATINOS IN IN
IN IN EDUCATION IN DOING THAT.
AND AND I I PUT IT THIS WAY MY
DISTRICT -- I HAVE A A SCHOOLS
PREDOMINATE LATINO WHERE THEY
HAVE -- PEOPLE GOING TO YALE.
AND TO STANFORD.
WITH WITH TWO BLOCKS AWAY.
GET ONE POINT [inaudible]
NINE LATINO.
WHAT THE HECK ARE THEY DOING
OVER HERE WHAT IS THIS PRINCIPLE
DOING OVER HERE?
WAS IS LATINA DOING -- HERE.
TO THIS SITE TEAM IS NOT DOING
OR VICE VERSA.
SO I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LEADERSHIP.
AND SO MAYBE THAT COULD BE PART
OF OUR DISCUSSION NEXT TIME.
BECAUSE IT GOES TO WHAT THE
SCHOOL BOARD YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT HOW THAT MONEY OF GET
DISBURSED TO DANNY GOES TO
PRINCIPLE DAY THEN MAKE A
DECISION.
AND WE ALL WE CAN DO IS JUST
SEND THE MONEY THAT.
ALL WE CAN DO IT JUST TO THE
POLICY AND THEN SEND IT DOWN.
WE GOT HAVE A SERIOUS DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHO UTILIZING.
THESE BONDS. TO THE FULLEST.
BECAUSE THAT IS PART OF AT THE
END OF THE DAY WHETHER.
YOUR PROGRAM IS IS FOR AFTER
AMERICANS.
I THINK THE SAME PRINCIPLES WILL
WORK WELL. FOR TEEN ONLY.
API NATIVE AMERICANS SAY IF IT
DOESN'T IT'S ALL TRANSFERABLE
THAT'S RIGHT AND AND SO -- HOW
DO WE TRANSFER WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME HOW DO
WE TRANSFERRED THIS?
SUCCESS AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THIS ARGUMENT BETWEEN CHARTER IN
PUBLIC ALL THE TIME BECAUSE THEY
BOTH ARE HAVING SUCCESSES BUT
THEY'RE NOT PULLING ALL TO GET
IT.
IT IT DRIVES US CRAZY I WILL
TELL YOU THAT RIGHT NOW IT
DRIVES.
ALL OF US HERE AND NOT.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THE ANSWER
IS THERE.
BUT IT'S NOT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
TO MAKE IT FLORES ARE TRAINED
TRAINED ADMINISTRATOR OR
SOMETHING.
AND SO MAYBE WE THEIR NEXUS THE
HAVE THAT CAN HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND THEN JUST JUST
BRINGING IN MORE PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT.
EVEN NATIVE AMERICANS.
EXACTLY THERE IT DAM NUMBERS ARE.
IF YOU THINK AFTER AMERICANS AND
LATINOS ARE BAD.
NATIVE AMERICANS IN THE STATE
AND HOW WE TREAT THEM AS
CRIMINAL CRIMINAL.
INSTRUMENT SO IT WOULD.
YES AND IS A THERE'S A COMMITTEE
DOES LOOKING INTO THAT.
AND SO -- I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE.
THAT PARTICIPATED THAT.
ADDICTIVE IS VERY EFFECTIVE --
LOOKS LIKE A CHECKBOOK IS ARE
YOU START TO WRITE CHECKS ON IT
I'M WORK ON THAT BUT I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU KNOW EVERYONE
IT'S SPOKEN EVERYBODY THAT'S
HERE.
CONTINUE TO GIVE HIS INPUT
BECAUSE WE NEED TO DO FOLLOW UP
SO WE CAN MAKE THIS TANGIBLE
CADETS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING SO
AGAIN WE HAVE TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THIS COMMITTEE
STANDS ADJOURNED